I'm Jennifer Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind the scene stories that only two people who are there can tell you. We're the office ladies. It is season 4. Season 4.
我是詹妮弗·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极版《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并提供只有当时身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎。第四季开始了。第四季。
Holy G-Locka-moly! It's fun run. It's fun run part 1. That's right. Because fun run was an hour long episode, so once again, we're going to break it down into two parts. Today is fun run part 1. Written by Greg Daniels., written by Greg Daniels, directed by Greg Daniels.
天哪，太惊险了！是慈善赛跑。慈善赛跑第一部分。没错。因为慈善赛跑是一集时长一小时的节目，所以我们再次把它拆成两部分。今天是慈善赛跑第一部分。由格雷格·丹尼尔斯编剧，格雷格·丹尼尔斯编剧，格雷格·丹尼尔斯执导。
So much happens in Fun Run. It needs to be two episodes. It really does. Oh, for sure. For sure. Here is a summary of just part one. Yeah, let's hear it. Yeah, let's hear it. Okay. Michael accidentally hits Meredith with his car and breaks her pelvis. There's so much there already. He gets the whole gang to visit her in the hospital and later discovers she may also have rabies. Angela asked Dwight to give medicine to her cat sprinkles while she visits Meredith in the hospital, but when Dwight returns, he announces that sprinkles is dead and he puts sprinkles in the freezer. In the freezer!
《慈善赛跑》里发生的事情太多了。它必须分成两集。确实如此。哦，肯定的。绝对的。以下仅为第一部分的总结。是的，听听看。是的，听听看。好的。迈克尔开车不小心撞了梅雷迪思，撞断了她的骨盆。里面已经有这么多内容了。他让一帮人去医院看望她，后来发现她可能还得了狂犬病。安吉拉在去医院看望梅雷迪思期间，拜託德怀特给她的猫“洒洒”喂药，但当德怀特回来时，他宣布“洒洒”死了，并把“洒洒”放进了冰箱。放进冰箱里！
Also, your television was on. Yeah, my television was on and sprinkles is in the freezer. Meanwhile, everyone wants to know if Jim and Pam are dating. They insist they're not, they say they're just friends, but Kevin is not convinced. Kevin really has a being as bonded about it. Yeah, why does Kevin care so much? I don't know, he's obsessed.
还有，你的电视开着。对，我的电视开着，“洒洒”在冰箱里。与此同时，所有人都想知道吉姆和帕姆是不是在约会。他们坚称没有，他们说只是朋友，但凯文并不相信。凯文对此真的有种执念。对啊，为什么凯文这么在意？我不知道，他着迷了。
Because this episode begins so dramatically, we felt like we needed to speak with the woman at the center of this episode. Absolutely. We need to talk to Kate Flannery about getting hit by that car. Yes. So, guys, Kate, chatted with us, say, um, will you play the interview? Kate Flannery is here today, you guys, with her tiny teacup. Hi, Kate. How are you?
因为这一集的开局非常戏剧化，我们觉得有必要和这一集核心的这位女性聊聊。绝对的。我们需要和凯特·弗兰纳里聊聊被那辆车撞的经历。是的。所以，大家，凯特和我们聊了聊，嗯，你会播放这段采访吗？各位，凯特·弗兰纳里今天带着她的小茶杯来了。嗨，凯特。你好吗？
Great how you guys doing. It's so nice to see you. Wait, we have to get a picture of you with that teacup. Cody, will you take a picture? It's not tiny. It's a regular-sized teacup. What's tiny about that? I don't believe you.
很好，你们怎么样？很高兴见到你们。等等，我们得拍一张你和那个茶杯的合影。科迪，你能拍张照吗？它不小。这是一个正常大小的茶杯。那有什么小的？我才不信。
It looks tiny. It's regular. Oh my gosh. And you have a little cup and saucer. Here's the guys. Kate Flannery is one of the classiest gals. Her home is spectacular. It is decorated like it's out of architectural digest. It is every little thing is amazing. And I am not surprised at all that you look so put together and you're having your tea in a proper cup and saucer. Oh my gosh, wait, now I got my phone on.
它看起来很小。它是正常的。哦，天哪。你还有一个小杯子和茶托。各位，凯特·弗兰纳里是最优雅的女士之一。她的家美极了。它的装修就像出自《建筑文摘》一样。每一个小细节都令人惊叹。你看起来那么精致，而且用精致的杯子和茶托喝茶，我一点也不感到惊讶。哦，天哪，等等，现在我手机接通了。
You can still call me. Just get on for a phone call. Sorry. Take it on air. Take it on air. Who is it? Let's talk to them. I think it was a potential spam, so I hung up on them.
你还是可以打给我。接个电话就行。抱歉。直播接听。直播接听。是谁？我们跟他们聊聊吧。我觉得这可能是垃圾来电，所以我挂断了。
I'm sorry. I can't get locked in a time share just for you for the bit. I'm sorry, you guys. I can't. It's so good to see you. You don't say we spent every day together for nine years. I'm sorry you guys. I can't. It's so good to see you. You know what I'm saying? We spent every day together for nine years. I know. Oh my god. I know. It was so much like a real office job in that respect. It was at our desks. And the fluorescent light. Yes. I mean, that has a real effect on you. And the snacks. Come on. That was the best spread. Oh God, we
我很抱歉。我可不能为了节目被套牢在分时度假里。我很抱歉，伙计们。我不能。很高兴见到你们。你知道我在说什么吗？我们九年来每天都在一起。我很抱歉，伙计们。我不能。很高兴见到你们。你知道我在说什么吗？我们九年来每天都在一起。我知道。哦，天哪。我知道。从这方面来看，这很像一份真正的办公室工作。我们坐在办公桌前。还有荧光灯。是的。我的意思是，那对你真的有影响。还有零食。拜托。那是最好的零食。哦，天哪，我们
have the best best food ever. It's all my dad ever talked about all the years that he visited. And I would pepper him with questions about so Steve Carellate lunch with us today. Wasn't that great? And he was like, did you see the steak? Like hat? It was always about the food. Bill Kinsey. Oh Kate, it's so good to see you. And Jenna, you guys. You boys. Kate, we always like to start by asking people how they came to be on the office. I actually auditioned for the pilot for the part of Jan. Alzenjohn said, I think you're really right for this show, but I don't know if this is your part. So clearly they went a different way with the Lord heart. And Lohan behold, you guys shot the pilot.
有有史以来最好吃的食物。这也是我父亲在他来访的那些年里一直谈论的事情。我会抛出各种问题问他，比如史蒂夫·卡瑞尔今天和我们一起吃午饭了吗？是不是很棒？他就会说，你看到牛排了吗？像帽子一样？总是离不开食物。比尔·金西。哦，凯特，很高兴见到你们。还有詹娜，你们。你们这些家伙。凯特，我们总是喜欢先问问大家是怎么加入《办公室》的。我其实为试播集试镜过简这个角色。阿森·琼斯说：“我觉得你真的很适合这个节目，但我不知道这算不算你的角色。”所以很明显，他们在罗德·哈特身上走了另一条路。正如你所料，你们拍了试播集。
I remember that summer, I was doing a sketch show once a week that was timed. It was a two minute sketch show. So literally at two minutes, the lights would go out. It was this live show in Hollywood at this theater on Melrose with the school art. One of the school art brothers, Randy, was doing a sketch right before me.
我记得那个夏天，我每周做一次定时的小品秀。这是一个两分钟的小品秀。所以到了两分钟，灯就会灭。这是好莱坞的一场现场表演，在梅尔罗斯的一家剧院里，和艺术学校一起。艺术学校兄弟之一的兰迪就在我之前演了一个小品。
He was like, if you've been watching that British show the office, I'm so obsessed with it. He was like the first person really tell me about it. I was like, yeah, I've seen a little bit, he goes, you got to watch the whole thing. So I kind of got obsessed and then come September, late August, early September, I had an audition. I couldn't make the first one because I was in Chicago with my aunt. And then I just came, I figured the part was going to get taken. And they had another session a few days later. And I went in and I read and I remember Alison Jones said, no makeup. And like usually in LA, you know, that means light, you know, mascara,
他说，如果你一直在看英国的那部剧《办公室》，我简直对它着迷了。他就像是第一个真正向我提起它的人。我说，是的，我稍微看了一点，他说，你得把整部剧都看完。所以我有点着迷了，然后到了九月份，八月下旬，九月初，我有一个试镜。我没赶上第一场，因为我和我姑妈在芝加哥。然后我直接去了，我想这个角色肯定被选走了。几天后他们还有另一场试镜。我进去了，读了剧本，我记得艾莉森·琼斯说，不准化妆。就像在洛杉矶通常那样，你知道，那意味着淡淡的，你知道，睫毛膏，
some foundation. Yeah. It means something. It never really means no makeup. No, and they're like literally, she's literally had a box of tissue. She's like, no makeup. No, no. And they were like literally, she's literally had a box of tissues. She's like, no makeup. Why pit off? Get off, right? Anyway, and then I just remember there were a few actresses that I knew from Chicago that were there.
一些粉底。是的。那是有含义的。其实从来不意味着不化任何妆。不，他们简直，她手里拿了一盒纸巾。她说，不准化妆。不，不。他们简直，她手里拿了一盒纸巾。她说，不准化妆。出来，出来，对吧？不管怎样，然后我只记得有几个我认识的芝加哥女演员也在那里。
And I felt like they booked everything. I'm like, I'm never going to get this. But I just remember that room was Ken Quapis and Greg and Alison Jones. And I'm sure Paul, Lee, I'm sure they were, you know, Mike, sure, I'm sure all the producers were there, the writer of producers, it was like the most unique experience I think I'd ever had in an audition. And then when I came out, I got home and then Alison told me to go to Gower and do it again,
我觉得她们接了所有的通告。我想：我永远也拿不到这个角色了。但我只记得那个房间里有肯·夸皮斯、格雷格和艾莉森·琼斯。我敢肯定保罗、李也在，我敢肯定迈克尔也在，我敢肯定所有的制片人都在，编剧兼制片人，那是我经历过的最独特的试镜体验。然后当我出来时，我回到家，然后艾莉森叫我去高尔街再试一次，
do it one more time and do less, less, less, do less. And then by the time I got home from there, I found out that I got the part. What? You booked it on the drive home? Is that girl? Wait, I didn't have a cell phone. So I didn't know told that home. That every actor's dream. You didn't have a cell phone, so you didn't know.
再试一次，而且要少演，少演，再少演。然后等我从那儿回到家时，我发现我得到这个角色了。什么？你在开车回家的路上就定下来了？真的吗？等等，我没有手机。所以我到家才知道。那是每个演员的梦想。你没有手机，所以你不知道。
Those were the days, man. Like, you know what? You can't, they couldn't get hold of you. You found out at home. I was playing hard to get on the drive home. Wow. Well, Kate, I was so excited. Because hard to get on the drive home. Wow. Well, Kate, I was so excited because when you walked on the set that day, Kate and I had been doing an improv show called Bitch Planet.
那是属于过去的时代，老兄。就像，你知道吗？你不能，他们联系不上你。你到家才知道。我在开车回家的路上玩起了欲擒故纵。哇。好吧，凯特，我太兴奋了。因为在开车回家的路上玩欲擒故纵。哇。好吧，凯特，我太兴奋了，因为那天你走到片场时，凯特和我一直在做一个叫《贱人星球》的即兴表演秀。
All Chick improv. All Chick improv. And we'd been doing that for years. And then all of a sudden my good friend was going to be sitting like right behind me for years. That was just amazing. Who knew when when four people win our audience on a Sunday night for our show at 10 o'clock. Kate, do you remember what your audition scene was? Yeah, it was from the Alliance. It was the whole reaction to the surprise party and Michael reading the birthday card and insulting Meredith like crazy.
纯女生即兴表演。纯女生即兴表演。我们做这个已经好几年了。然后突然间，我的好朋友要在接下来的好几年里坐在我身后。这真是太棒了。谁知道当有四个人在周日晚上十点来看我们的演出时，凯特，你还记得你的试镜场景是什么吗？是的，是关于“联盟”那一集的。那是整个对于惊喜派对的反应，以及迈克尔读生日卡片并疯狂侮辱梅雷迪思的场景。
Yes, amazing. Yeah, it was so awesome. So awesome, so awkward, so awful. So awful. Happy birthday. Happy birthday. Well, Kate, we've talked a lot on this show about how once we were filming in that bullpen, we were all in the scene. And so we were all
是的，太棒了。是的，太棒了，太尴尬了，太糟糕了。太糟糕了。生日快乐。生日快乐。好吧，凯特，我们在节目中讨论过很多次，一旦我们在那个办公区拍摄，我们所有人都在场景里。所以我们都是
each other's background. And that's very unique. It's not like that on a lot of shows, right? Right. So we've sort of talked about the things we did in the background. We talked about how Phyllis looked at Gates. Remember she looked at Gates for her house for years. I remember they told us, they told me when I booked the job that I was supposed to bring paperwork because they really wanted us to be looking like we were working. when I booked the job that I was supposed to bring paperwork because they really wanted us to be looking like we were working. And I loved that suggestion. I thought it was so, like, it's so method because the no one is suddenly acting like they're
彼此的背景。这非常独特。很多节目都不是这样的，对吧？对。所以我们大致聊了聊我们在背景里做的事情。我们聊了菲利斯看盖茨的样子。还记得她多年来一直看着盖茨的房子吗我记得他们告诉我，当我得到这份工作时，他们告诉我要带一些纸工作为道具，因为他们真的希望我们看起来像在工作。当我得到这份工作时，他们告诉我要带一些纸工作为道具，因为他们真的希望我们看起来像在工作。我非常喜欢这个建议。我觉得这太棒了，就像是演技派的做法，因为没有人突然假装在
working, they're actually working, and the camera catches them, which makes so much more sense. So I actually brought my taxes for season. I wanted to say Kate, I have a memory of you opening your mail and like, I did. I did. I brought a bag of stuff. And I think I also like snuck reading a book,
工作，他们其实就是在工作，而镜头捕捉到了他们，这合理多了。所以我实际上把那一季的税单带来了。我想说的是，凯特，我记得你曾打开信箱，就像——没错，我带了。我带了一袋东西。而且我想我还偷偷看了一本书，
which is kind of like a thing that people do in an office anyway sometimes. Well, especially Meredith, well, I don't know. Does Meredith read a lot? Maybe not. I got into solitary or clearly. That was like my main background choice for so much. But that was so much because the back of my head wasn't so much of it that I, my, my
这有点像人们在办公室里有时会做的事情。好吧，特别是梅雷迪思，好吧，我不知道。梅雷迪思读很多书吗？也许没有。我显然是在玩纸牌接龙。那成了我大部分时间的背景选择。但很大程度上是因为我的后脑勺——很多时候，我的
can't, my screen was caught all the time on my computer. So I would just rather than like go to some file at the last minute, I would just dump into solitaire because I knew I could just get right back into it. And I thought it was a funny thing for Meredith to be multitasking all the time with the game. So it's too much. Well, you became really, really good at it. I actually created and I would have many, many a competition and I whooped his ass. I am still sort of hung up on the fact that they told you to come to set and bring paper work to the day.
屏幕在电脑上一直被拍到。所以比起临时去找某个文件，我宁愿直接玩纸牌接龙，因为我知道我可以马上切回那个状态。我觉得梅雷迪思一直在用游戏处理多重任务是一件很有趣的事。所以太多了。好吧，你玩得真的，真的很好。我其实创造了，我会有很多很多的比赛，而且我打得他们落花流水。我还是有点纠结于他们竟然让你那天去片场带纸质文件。
Do they tell you that? They don't tell you that? No. You know, I don't remember that specifically, but I did bring some. I used to write down my grocery list a lot. I was constantly, or just general to-do lists. I would do, I would journal, you know, but with a paper and a pen.
他们有这样对你说吗？他们没跟你说吗？没有。你知道，我不记得具体是不是这样了，但我确实带了一些。我以前经常写我的购物清单。我一直在写，或者只是写一般的待事清单。我会写日记，你知道的，但用的是纸和笔。
So funny. No, Janet, you and I had a little system that we created. Do you remember this? You have to. It's one of my fondest memories of the show. What, what, what, what? We had specific boxes of other people's real life. Paperwork.
太搞笑了。不，詹娜，你和我有一个我们自己创建的小系统。你还记得这个吗？你肯定记得。这是我对这个节目最美好的回忆之一。什么，什么，什么，什么？我们有专门装别人真实生活纸质文件的盒子。
Yes. Phil Shae bought medical records. It was bizarre and these were seats. And I had this whole system where I was stapling and I had a whole like think certain things that would match and then I would bring them to you and then you would approve or disapprove sign. I remember this whole oh my god it was fantastic. It was amazing and it was very specific. My favorite thing about it Kate was that we would do this in the deep, deep, deep background when no one would appreciate it.
是的。菲尔·谢伊买来了医疗记录。这太离谱了，这些都是道具。我有一整套系统，我在装订，我还弄了一整套特定的文件要相匹配，然后我会把它们拿给你，接着你会批准或不批准并签字。我还记得这一切，哦天哪，太棒了。这太棒了，而且非常具体。关于它，我最喜欢的一点，凯特，就是我们会在极深、极深、极深的背景里做这个，当时根本没有人会注意到。
It was really just for us. And we would never break character. And we would argue not with each other, but sort of like with the system. Yes, we were mad at how they had to get these, yes, these alpha numeric characters that don't match any of the forms and are impossible to input into the computer We have this whole like thing. We were mad at at corporate that we would do This is the greatest job in the world. This is the cutest thing that I How is it that I was on top with you guys all these years? I didn't know I I didn't know you guys were doing this
这真的只是为了我们自己。而且我们从来不会出戏。我们会争论，不是跟彼此争论，而是跟那个系统争论。是的，我们很生气他们怎么能弄出这些——是的，这些字母数字字符，跟任何表格都不匹配，根本没法输入电脑。我们有一整套这样的流程。我们对公司很生气，我们会在背景里做这个。这是世界上最棒的工作。这太可爱了。怎么会这样，我这些年一直和你们在一起？我不知道，我不知道你们俩在干这个。
Do you know what Oscar Nunez would do with these health records? Oscar would find one that had something really peculiar and he'd circle it and highlight it and make it very important. And he would hand it to me in the middle of a scene with great authority. And it would say something like bulbous mass on eyelid, probably style, recommended to drain of the pus. And I'd be like, oh my God, I'm reading this in the background of a scene. We were so respectful though. Obviously, we never gave away anybody's name or medical condition on the show. I want to say, I have a memory that those forms were redacted, like that the real personal info was blacked out. Did I do that to the forms or is that real?
你知道奥斯卡·努涅斯会拿这些健康记录做什么吗？奥斯卡会找到一个有非常奇特症状的病例，把它圈起来，用荧光笔标出来，搞得好像非常重要一样。然后在某个场景拍摄的中间，他会极其严肃地把它交给我。上面会写着类似“眼睑上有球状肿块，可能是麦粒肿，建议排脓”之类的内容。而我会想，天哪，我居然在某个场景的背景里读这个。不过我们还是很尊重当事人的。很显然，我们从来没有在节目中泄露过任何人的名字或病情。我想说，我记忆中那些表格是被涂黑的，比如真实的个人信息被涂黑了。是我对表格做了这个处理，还是本来就是真的？
I think we did it to the forms. I literally think we did because I remember, sometimes there were a little bit, but not everything, not over, not every, yeah. I do remember address as being blacked out, but anyway guys, it was sort of creepy to know that you could buy old medical records. In those days, I'm sure now they're all computerized. And also the dates were from like three decades ago.
我想是我们对表格做了处理。我真的觉得是我们做的，因为我记得，有时它们会被涂黑一点，但不是全部，不是所有的，不是每一个，是的。我确实记得地址被涂黑了，但不管怎样，伙计们，知道你可以买到旧的医疗记录，感觉有点毛骨悚然。在那个年代，我相信现在它们全都是计算机化的。而且这些日期都是几十年前的。
It was like there's a lot of stuff in the 1960s. Yeah, the 80s was a big yeah. Yeah, it's so big. I love I love how we're trying to reassure people when the truth is we clearly had things we shouldn't have had. Oh my god. But you know what, let's keep trying to justify why it was okay. Well, it's fine. It's fine. It would happen at Dundermifflin's day to Dundermifflin. We did not share any. That's right.
就好像里面有很多20世纪60年代的东西。是的，80年代也是个大头，对吧。对，太经典了。我喜欢，我喜欢我们试图向人们保证真相时，我们明显带着不该带的东西。哦，天哪。但你知道吗，让我们继续试着证明为什么这是可以的。好吧，这没关系。没关系。这会在邓德米夫林的日常生活中发生。我们没有分享任何。没错。
That's a material. But I will say, what I loved about that and the realness of the paperwork, it kept, it just kept everything, it was like a little focus for the lens. Yeah. One of my favorite things was they had stacks and stacks of some type of time code documentation from these offices and they were on really thin like, like almost like the pages of a Bible thin, you know, and then they had all the little carbon slides in them. And I would sometimes smell the carpentry.
那是机密材料。但我得说，我喜欢的是那个和纸质文件的真实感，它让一切保持着焦点，就像镜头的一个小焦点。是的。我最喜欢的事情之一是，他们有来自这些办公室的一叠又一叠某种时间代码文档，它们是用非常薄的纸印的，几乎像圣经纸那么薄，你知道的，里面还有所有的小复写纸夹层。我有时会闻闻木工味。
I know. Because I like the smell. It's like the smell of like a sharpie. I like this smell. This isn't a true Hollywood story right now. Angela is getting high in the corner. Angela was sniffing the carbon in the background sometimes. This is how you got into character.
我懂。因为我喜欢那个味道。就像马克笔的味道。我喜欢这个味道。这不是一个真实的好莱坞故事。安吉拉在角落里嗨起来了。安吉拉有时会在背景里闻复写纸的气味。这就是你进入角色的方式。
I don't know. Well, you know, it's funny, because Ken Kwaapus would do that thing, you know, like the general tone at the beginning, when he would come. And this was all part of it, just like actually, you know, filming us working, just working and being like, you know,
我不知道。好吧，你知道，这很有趣，因为肯·夸皮斯会做那种事，你知道的，比如一开始的整体基调，当他走过来的时候。这也是其中的一部分，就像实际上，你知道的，拍摄我们工作，只是工作然后就像，你知道的，
who are you working? It's funny, people have asked me like, how did you say in character or whatever. I feel like those were our desks. So the crew really wasn't allowed to sit at our desk so it was it really did feel like an office job in that respect like you would get literally walk in to set and just go right to your desk yeah kind of like focusing and specific and really wonderful and it kept all of us in the game and we did it you
谁在工作？有趣的是，人们曾问我，你是怎么保持入戏诸如此类的。我觉得那是我们的办公桌。所以剧组真的不允许坐在我们的办公桌前，所以从这方面来看，它真的感觉像是一份办公室工作，就像你真的会走进片场直接走向你的办公桌，是的，有点像专注于特定事情，真的很棒，它让我们所有人都保持在状态中，而且我们做到了，
know what I wouldn't sit at anybody else's desk. No. Like, I would never just go sit down in Phyllis's chair. No. Right? That was like her space. Sometimes rain would sit at my desk to talk fantasy football with Brian.
你知道吗，我不会坐在任何其他人的办公桌前。不。就像，我绝不会随便去坐在菲利斯的椅子上。不。对吧？那是她的空间。有时候雷恩会坐在我的办公桌前和布莱恩聊梦幻足球。
Right. And I would have to come kick him out of my seat. But I just had such respect for the process. Like, I just feel like the focus was always in the right place for our show. Yeah. Yeah. And I feel like I didn't always have a lot of lines, obviously.
对。而我不得不去把他从我的座位上踢走。但我对这个流程有着极大的尊重。就好像，我觉得我们的节目的焦点总是在正确的地方。对。是的。而且我觉得我并不总是有很多台词，很明显。
But I feel like there was something that I felt like I was kind of holding the space for the reality that we were in. And that was very important to me. I was always very conscious of that. Well, we are super excited to talk to you about this amazing stunt that you did in this episode. I mean, holy cow, Kate, you get hit by a car.
但我觉得有些东西让我觉得我是在为我们所处的现实守住这个空间。这对我来说非常重要。我对此一直非常有意识。好吧，我们超级兴奋地和你聊聊你在这一集里做的那个惊人的特技。我的天啊，凯特，你被车撞了。
You get hit by a car. What was your first thought when you read this episode? Okay, I literally said, does she live? I literally said, does Meredith live? I literally said does Meredith live? I said it right away. And then I've been reading later that there's been article saying that one of the writers decided that they wanted a pitch that Meredith didn't live.
你被车撞了。当你读到这一集时，你的第一反应是什么？好吧，我literally（简直）说的是，她还活着吗？我literally说的是，梅雷迪思还活着吗？我literally说的是梅雷迪思还活着吗？我马上就说出来了。然后我后来读到一些文章说，其中一位编剧决定他们想提出一个意见，让梅雷迪思死掉。
And then I thought that was too dark. Greg thought it was too dark for my goal to have killed one of the employees of the company. Oh my God, how do you come back from that? Yeah, I'm not sure, I'm not sure, but I was like, but I remember, I was so conscious of it because I was like, I know this isn't a soap opera, like this can be it,
然后我觉得这太黑暗了。格雷格认为对于这部剧来说，杀掉公司的一个员工实在是太黑暗了。哦，天哪，这怎么收场？是的，我不确定，我不确定，但我记得，我对此太有意识了，因为我想，我知道这不是肥皂剧，这怎么可能发生，
but the first time we shot it, literally they played it almost like Meredith was a speed bump that he just went over. Because like you were laying on the ground and he rolled over you. I was underneath the wheel, literally. We finished shooting the episode and then I think two weeks later,
但我们第一次拍摄时，他们拍得几乎就像梅雷迪思是个减速带，他直接从她身上碾过去了。因为你躺在地上，他从你身上碾过去了。我 literalmente（简直）在车轮底下。我们拍完这一集，然后我想两周后，
Dave Rogers, our Emmy-winning editor, had an idea for an insert shot that he thought was so much more interesting than what we had shot, which was merit-at-hitting the glass. And he asked our UPM Ken Zabornak to try it out and show it to me. He like, Ken did it, do you think you'd do it? I mean, he obviously did not know me
戴夫·罗杰斯，我们获得艾美奖的剪辑师，想出一个插入镜头的点子，他觉得这个点子比我们之前拍的要有趣得多，也就是梅雷迪思撞到玻璃上的那一幕。他让我们的UPM肯·扎博纳克试一下，然后展示给我看。他就像，肯做了，你觉得你能做吗？我的意思是，他显然不了解我，
because I would have said yes anyway. I totally would have said yes. I was gonna say, you would say yes. I would have, but season one, I remember Greg, there was a shot of Dwight and Michael dress like Crockett and Tubbs from Miami Vice, from the Halloween party. Do you remember that?
因为我无论如何都会答应的。我绝对会答应的。我本来想说，你肯定会答应的。我确实会，但第一季的时候，我记得格雷格，有一个镜头是德怀特和迈克尔打扮成万圣节派对上《迈阿密风云》里的克罗克特和塔布斯。你还记得吗？
Yes, yes. And they had me dress up like Madonna. And I remember, it was like, it was maybe my second week there and I was like, oh, okay, I'll be Madonna, whatever. And like, they really went for it. I mean, I was like 1987 Madonna. I was wearing like a boostier.
是的，是的。他们让我打扮成麦当娜。我记得，那可能是我在那里的第二周，我想，哦，好吧，我会成为麦当娜，随便啦。而且，他们真的全力以赴了。我的意思是，我是1987年版的麦当娜。我穿着紧身胸衣。
It was nuts. I was just in the background. And I thought, there was something about that. It was like my responsibility to do whatever as full out as possible. I don't know. I was like, kind of up for anything. Because I remember Greg saying, is it okay. I don't know, I was like kind of up for anything. Cause I remember Greg saying,
这太疯狂了。我只是在背景里。我想，这其中有些东西。就像我的责任是尽可能全力以赴地做好每一件事。我不知道。我好像什么都愿意尝试。因为我记得格雷格问，这样可以吗？我不知道，我好像什么都愿意尝试。因为我记得格雷格问，
is it okay if you do this? And I was like, sure, like of course. So that started the whole merit of the saga, being full Madonna. I've created it all. I'm afraid. But I actually felt like it was so much fun to do the physical comedy.
如果你这样做可以吗？我说，当然，这还用说。于是这就开始了整个梅雷迪思传奇，扮演完全的麦当娜。这一切都是我创造的。恐怕是的。但实际上我觉得做肢体喜剧太有趣了。
Cause I have such a good time, I'm always had a good time doing that my whole career. But this was so up another level for sure. So literally when we went to shoot it, we had to shoot it again and Steve wasn't available. So Dan Beals, who was our PA, who was so young at the time, he had Steve's jacket on and shirt. So it was his hand that they would cut from. it was it's such a quick swipe like it you know so wait Dan was driving Well, he was just in the car in the car. I started in the center of the hood
因为我玩得很开心，我的整个职业生涯中做这个一直都很开心。但这绝对是另一个层次的提升。所以 literalmente（简直）当我们去拍的时候，我们不得不重新拍一遍，而史蒂夫没空。所以丹·比尔斯，我们的制片助理，当时还那么年轻，他穿着史蒂夫的夹克和衬衫。所以切到手的时候其实是他的手。这是一个非常快的动作，像，你知道的——等等，丹在开车？好吧，他只是在车里，在车里。我从发动机盖的中心开始，
I had to roll up to the glass and then roll off the car onto a giant mat and So you sort of had to like with force roll into that windshield on your own. You sort of slammed your body into the windshield and then slowly rolled off of it onto a mat in the parking lot. Yes. And I remember after like the fourth take or fifth take, Greg took me aside and we went to the back where the warehouse entrance is in that alley where we shot like where the bird, you know, where they had the bird funeral, you know, the alley.
我得滚到玻璃上，然后从车上滚到一个巨大的垫子上。所以你基本上得用力自己滚到那个挡风玻璃上。你基本上把身体猛撞到挡风玻璃上，然后慢慢从上面滚下来，落到停车场的一个垫子上。是的。我记得拍到第四条或第五条之后，格雷格把我拉到一边，我们走到后面仓库入口的那个小巷里，就是我们拍像鸟的那条巷子，你知道的，他们给鸟办葬礼的那条巷子。
Yeah. Yeah. He's like, okay, had the bird funeral, you know, the alley. Yeah, yeah, yeah. He's like, okay, come with me. And do some jumping jacks. He was like doing jumping jacks with me just to get me really loose. I love Greg so much. I mean, he's so Greg, by the way.
对。对。他说，好吧，给鸟办葬礼的那条巷子。对，对，对。他说，好吧，跟我来。然后做一些开合跳。他就像陪我一起做开合跳，只是为了让我彻底放松下来。我太喜欢格雷格了。我的意思是，顺便说一句，他太格雷格了。
He's the great, like the greatest. It's funny, I just recently saw Dave Rogers sent me an outtake, another take that they didn't use. And I actually did an extra spin in there, which I actually thought was a little funnier, but I'm just so used to watching the one thing I think it just caught me by surprise. So wait there is a take of you out in the universe where you roll you flip forward twice into the windshield. No once in
他是最棒的，最棒的。有趣的是，我最近看到戴夫·罗杰斯发给我一个未采用的片段，那是另一个他们没用的镜头。我其实在里面多转了一圈，我当时觉得那个其实稍微更好笑一点，但我太习惯看最终播出的那版了，我觉得那个只是让我有点意外。等等，世界上真的存在这样一个镜头：你滚的时候在挡风玻璃上连续向前翻滚了两次？不，在挡风玻璃上是
the worship but then I flip twice off the car. Oh so I like it's insane. It's insane. Well guys, at 53 seconds, you can see Kate's face up against the chair. And I'm telling you, after we shot that, I remember they were using it in the promos for the episode because it was the first episode of season four, fun run. I remember Joaquin Phoenix canceled it the last minute for the tonight show, so they asked me basically because of the promo. It was so much fun like they actually wanted me on the tonight show. So they asked me, basically because of the promo, it was so much fun, like they actually wanted me on the tonight show. So that was the first time I did that.
一次，但接着我在车下翻滚了两次。哦，所以我的意思是，这太疯狂了。这太疯狂了。好吧，伙计们，在53秒的时候，你可以看到凯特的脸贴着椅子。我告诉你们，我们拍完那个之后，我记得他们在该集的宣传片里用了这个镜头，因为这是第四季的第一集，慈善赛跑。我记得华金·菲尼克斯最后关头取消了今夜秀的通告，所以他们基本上因为这个宣传片才找的我。太有趣了，他们实际上想让我上今夜秀。所以那是第一次我做这件事。
That was so awesome. Well, Kate, Kate, you're just like a rock star. I mean, I have to ask you though, if you're rolling with force into a windshield over and over and rolling off where you saw, did you like, we had to match what we shot before, because they weren't sure about the before, if they were gonna see us before.
太棒了。好吧，凯特，凯特，你简直就像个摇滚明星。不过我不得不问你，如果你一次又一次地用力滚向挡风玻璃然后滚下来，你在看的时候，我们得跟之前拍的镜头接上，因为他们不确定之前的效果，不确定能不能拍到我们之前的样子。
So I had to match the clothes and I was wearing short sleeves and like a denim jumper. Yeah. Like a kindergarten teacher. And I remember the Emmys were like the next week and I was so bruised. How do you use like body makeup?
所以我得服装连戏，我穿着短袖和一件牛仔连身裙。是的。就像个幼儿园老师。我记得艾美奖就在接下来的一周举行，我身上全都是瘀青。你会用身体彩妆吗？
Yeah, because I think if they knew they were gonna do the stunt that way, they probably would have padded you up and dressed you up. Totally. Yeah, totally. Yeah. Oh my gosh, that's crazy. Well, Kate, you did so many stunts on the show. Was this your favorite?
对，因为我想如果他们知道他们要那样拍特技，他们可能会给你垫上护具，穿上特技服装。完全会。是的，完全会。哦，天哪，太疯狂了。好吧，凯特，你在节目中做了那么多特技。这是你最喜欢的吗？
Do you have a favorite? I think so. This was my favorite. I also loved being so weird. I was on top of the men's room stall when Dwight comes where I was planking. Meredith is planking. Yes, yes. Dwight comes in with a fire extinguisher
你有一个最喜欢的吗？我想是的。这是我最喜欢的。我也很喜欢那些古怪的桥段。当德怀特进来时，我正待在男厕所隔间的门板上，我在做平板支撑。梅雷迪思在做平板支撑。是的，是的。德怀特拿着一个灭火器走进来，
and just blows her off into the stall. Yeah. We used the real men's room where video village were the guests were, those two bathrooms. Yes, yeah, yeah, yeah. And they put like this weird flim flam mattress on top. And I was like, fingers crossed, I don't go the other way because there was nothing on the other side. Because I had a balance.
直接把她喷进隔间里。是的。我们用了真正的男厕所，也就是摄像监控（Video Village）和嘉宾用的那两个洗手间。是的，对，对，对。他们还在上面放了一个奇怪的简易床垫。我当时想，老天保佑我可别往那边倒，因为那边什么都没有。因为我得保持平衡。
That was so crazy. And it was really the bedroom. I'm like, okay, and this hopefully I don't land too hard because then I'm going to hit the toilet. It's so bizarre. But it's life. I want to give some props to your athleticism. I know that Angela has often tried to go for my athleticism. Here we go.
太疯狂了。而且那真的是男厕所。我想，好吧，希望我落地不要太猛，不然我就要撞到马桶了。太诡异了。但这这就是生活。我想对你的运动能力赞赏一番。我知道安吉拉经常试图挑战我的运动能力。我们来了。
No, it's okay. I'm not going back to that anymore than I just did. But Kate, you are amazingly athletic. I mean, in doing all these stunts, it doesn't surprise me. I mean, we know that you were on dancing with the stars and you were amazing, but you also did your lounge show, the lampshades for years and years and years, and I remember coming to see you in that, and you do this deep squat repeatedly, repeatedly, and you kick your leg up. And I was like, oh my gosh, I feel like they got so lucky with you.
不，没关系。我不会再重提刚才的话了。不过，凯特，你的运动能力惊人。我的意思是，看你做所有这些特技，我一点也不觉得奇怪。我的意思是，我们知道你参加过《与星共舞》，表现惊艳，但你还连续多年举办你的酒廊演出“灯罩剧团”，我记得我去看过你的演出，你要重复不断地做深蹲，然后把腿高高踢起。当时我就想，天哪，我觉得他们选到你真是太幸运了。
As Meredith, because you were qualified for these stunts. That's so sweet. I feel like for me too, it was empowering. Like I did not do the stunt with my hair on fire. I did do all the stuff in the parking lot of Moroccan Christmas. I just didn't do hair on fire. And the bat, you did the bat. That was crazy and you really sold it. So crazy. And then I didn't do hair and fire. And the bat, you did the bat, that was crazy,
作为梅雷迪思，因为你完全胜任这些特技。太贴心了。我觉得对我来说，这也是一种赋权。比如我拍“头发着火”时没有用特技替身。我在《摩洛哥圣诞节》的停车场里确实做了所有的动作。我只是没有真的让头发着火。还有蝙蝠，你处理了蝙蝠那场戏。太疯狂了，而且你演得太逼真了。太疯狂了。然后我实际上没有剃光头，我为此戴了个光头套。所以我觉得那是两个，好吧，我觉得你没真的剃头也没关系。
and you really sold it. So crazy, and then I didn't actually shave my head, I had a bald cap for that. So I feel like those are the two, like, okay. But I think it's okay that you let your hair be. You know what I'm saying? I think Greg was disappointed, though. Yeah, it's like the first time I was like, nope,
你知道我在说什么吗？不过我想格雷格当时可能会有点失望。是的，就像那是我第一次说：“不，我可不干这个。”
not doing that, like. Well, can we talk a little bit about the moment in this episode where we're all in the hospital? We've all come to see you. My memory of this was, it was so hard to get through those scenes without laughing. In fact, you see us break. I fully break in the episode.
好吧，我们能聊聊这一集里我们都在医院的那场戏吗？我们都去看望你了。我对这幕的记忆是，要在不笑场的情况下拍完这些戏太难了。事实上，你能看到我们笑场了。我在剧中彻底笑场了。
That was a great fun run. Yeah. What are your memories of shooting in the hospital? I remember there was one scene where Dwight talks about the fact that if they pulled the plug, you know, basically the energy, like they were wasting money keeping you going. I loved it when you were like, do not.
那是一次非常棒的慈善赛跑。是的。你对在医院拍摄有什么回忆？我记得有一场戏，德怀特谈到如果他们拔掉维持生命的插头，你知道的，基本上就是能量，他们就是在浪费钱维持你的生命。我最喜欢你当时说：“千万别。”
I love the plug. Don't pull any plug. Oh my God, it's so good. And I remember the take when Steve just, as an apology, he's trying to get an apology out of me and I won't apologize, I won't apologize. And so he just decides to climb into the bed with me. And I feel like I had a slight delayed reaction,
我喜欢那个拔插头。别拔任何插头。哦，天哪，太棒了。我记得有一条，史蒂夫作为道歉，他试图向我道歉，而我就是不肯道歉，我就是不肯道歉。于是他决定直接爬到我的病床上。我觉得我当时反应稍微慢了半拍，
but I'm like, I just started screaming because I'm like, like, well we were also surprised because he improvised that. And you even see all of us, we sort of like freeze, and then we're like, Michael said, yes, yes. It really took us by surprise totally totally well Kate another question we like to ask our guests is if they took anything with them when the show wrapped how dare you oh what do you have I've always wore it like a cross saddle.
但我当时——我直接尖叫起来，因为我想——好吧，我们也都很吃惊，因为那是他即兴发挥的。你甚至可以看到我们所有人都僵住了，然后我们想：迈克尔说了，“是的，是的。”这真的完全、完全出乎我们的意料。好吧，凯特，我们喜欢问嘉宾的另一个问题是，节目杀青时他们有没有顺走什么东西。你怎么敢！哦，你有什么？我一直把它当斜挎包背着。
Yeah. Yeah. You satcheled it. And I left everything in it that was still in there. So this is why I still had the marriage union of Pamela Morgan Beasley and James Duncan Halpert. Is that our wedding? Yes, it's the program.
是的。是的，你把它当斜挎包了。而且我把里面所有剩下的东西都留在里面了。这就是为什么我至今还保留着帕梅拉·摩根·比斯利和詹姆斯·邓肯·哈珀特的结婚请柬。那是我们的婚礼吗？是的，这是流程单。
So this is what I did. It's our wedding party. The wedding party. And this is what I did. It's our wedding program. It's our wedding program. And the wedding party. Yes, this is what I showed on some good news with John Krizenski when we did our wedding dance. Oh my gosh.
这就是我留下的东西。这是我们的婚礼派对。婚礼派对。这就是我留下的东西。这是我们的婚礼流程单。这是我们的婚礼流程单。还有婚礼派对。是的，这就是我在约翰·卡拉辛斯基的《Some Good News》节目中展示的那张，当时我们跳了婚礼舞蹈。哦，天哪。
Is that crazy? That is so, that you would just tuck it in your purse and you still have it. I did. We would do that, though. We would get prop purses. And like if we had props, we would just put them in our purse.
是不是很疯狂？太疯狂了，你居然把它塞进钱包里，而且到现在还留着。我留着呢。我们过去经常那样做。我们会拿到道具钱包。如果我们有道具，我们就会直接把它们放进钱包里。
Totally. Totally. Yeah. Oh my gosh. What else do I have in here? I think I have. Do you have some old sides? I do have sides. But I also have Swini Todd from when Andy was performing in that theater.
完全是这样。完全是这样。是的。哦，天哪。这里面还有什么？我想我有。你有一些旧台词本吗？我确实有台词本。但我还有安迪在那个剧院演出时的《理发师陶德》的场刊。
Wow. And I have Church of Angels, Cecilia Marie Helpert, when she got a christened. CC's christening. Oh my gosh. Kate Kate these are amazing. No. Well Kate fans love Meredith and you know we're gonna be hitting you up. We've got a few more episodes to cover before we're done here. Before we say goodbye is there anything we can share with everyone like where to find you what you're up to? Yes, I, well on Instagram at the Real Kate Flannery on Twitter at Kate Flannery, I got to a little rob in place
哇。还有西莉亚·玛丽·哈珀特的“天使教堂”，那是她受洗的时候。西西的洗礼。哦，天哪，凯特，凯特，这些太棒了。不。好吧，凯特，粉丝们深爱着梅雷迪思，你知道我们会继续找你的。我们在结束之前还有几集要回顾呢。在我们道别之前，有什么是我们可以和大家分享的吗，比如在哪里可以找到你，你最近在忙什么？是的，我，嗯，在Instagram上是 @TheRealKateFlannery，在Twitter上是 @KateFlannery，我每周在K镇演出一次单口喜剧。我开玩笑的。但其实我正在为“丰盛费城”（Philabundance）做一些慈善工作，这是费城最大的食物银行。那是我的家乡。我正在和WMMR合作，那是当地的大型广播电台。他们一直有普雷斯顿和史蒂夫主持的大型早间节目。
once a week in K-Town. I'm saying that. But I'm actually doing some charity work for Phil Abundance, which is the biggest food bank in Philadelphia. That's my hometown. I'm working with WMMR, which is the big radio station. They always have the big morning show with Preston and Steve.
我做这个节目已经好几年了。它离我爸爸的房子literally只有五分钟路程。我从床上滚起来就能去。如果我在城里，我偶尔会不小心溜出一个四字脏话。所以他们在控制台上literally有一个按钮，叫做“弗兰纳里按钮”，因为以前有四秒钟，你知道的，五秒钟延迟规则，就像，哦，他们有，我的意思是，FCC（联邦通信委员会）天哪，太疯狂了。不管怎样，我太爱这些家伙了，他们正在产生如此巨大的影响。
And I've been doing this show for years. And it's literally like five minutes for my dad's house. Like I will roll out of bed. And if I'm in town, I just occasionally sometimes let a four-letter word slip. So they literally have a button on their panel that says the flannery button, because it was a four-second you know, five second rule like, oh, they had, I mean, those FCC gosh, it's crazy. But anyway, I love these guys so much and they're making such a difference.
“丰盛费城”正在全力推进这项工作。他们总是在感恩节前夕这样做，但今年由于大流行病以及如此多的家庭陷入困境，有那么多的企业无法正常营业，而且我们必须等待直到我们能够再次团聚在一起，我们终将再次团聚。但在此期间，你知道的，大家可以去 filibundance.org，我会为他们做一点宣传，我会的。太棒了。我们应该提一下你是宾夕法尼亚人。是的。还有你的家人，你爸爸在费城开了一家酒吧。那家酒吧叫什么名字？“兰姆奥尔韦斯酒馆”（Lamb Always Tavern）。他整晚没睡都在想名字。不，我开玩笑的。名字是我外祖母想出来的。好吧，凯特，我们很高兴你这样回馈费城。我们肯定会在社交媒体上发布大家可以找到这个信息的地方。
Phil abundance is, they're doing a huge push. They always do it right before Thanksgiving, but this year is even bigger because of the pandemic and because so many families are in need and there's so many businesses that are not happening and that we have to wait until we can all be together again and we will be together again. But in the meantime, you know, you guys can go to filibundance.org and I'm going to be doing some little bit of press for them and I'll be. So great. And we should have mentioned that you're from Pennsylvania. Yes. And that your family, your dad had a bar in Philly. What was the name of the bar? Lamb always tavern. He was up all night trying to figure out a name. No, I'm just kidding. My grandmother came up with the name. Well, Kate, we love that you are given back to Philly like that. And we'll definitely, you know, we'll put in our socials where people can find that.
那太棒了。非常感谢你们。伙计们，我爱你们。很高兴见到你们。我也爱你们。非常感谢。太棒了。你们一定要再来。我很乐意。哦，我们回来了。安吉拉，太棒了。和凯特聊天。她看起来美丽动人。我们通过Zoom为我们的播客采访了很多人，大多数人出镜时都一团糟。凯特·弗兰纳里可不是。没有。她看起来棒极了，凯特，太有趣了，我们对你感激不尽，我们还有很多内容要讲，我们最好抓紧时间。是的。让我们来剖析这一集吧，女士们。
That would be awesome. Thank you so much. You guys, I love you. So great to see you. Love you too. Thank you so much. This was amazing. You have to come back. I would love to. Oh, we are back. Angela, that was so great. Talking with Kate. She looks beautiful, stunning. We have been talking to a lot of people through Zoom for our podcast, and most people show up like a hot mess. Not Kate Flannery. No. She looked amazing, and Kate, that was so fun, and we can't thank you enough and we have a lot to cover We better get into it. Yes. Let's break down this episode lady
首先，詹娜，我想与你分享本周我们拍摄这一集时你在做的事情，准备好了吗？好的。有人去挖旧邮件了。哦，我有点害怕。别害怕，虽然我可以把它彻底删光，但你也可以。哦，天哪。好吧，在2007年7月31日，整个剧组收到了一封邮件，
First of all Jenna, I would like to share with you what you were doing this week that we filmed this are you ready? Okay Someone went digging into old emails Oh, I'm kind of scared. Don't be scared, although I could burn it to the ground, but so could you. Oh, dear. Okay, on July 31, 2007, the whole cast got an email
发件人是肯·扎博纳克。上面写着：大家好，关于本周五，即8月3日，这是我们当天的日程安排。上午8点45分。在NBC环球制片厂报到参加性骚扰研讨会。地点在3号摄影棚。上午9点，性骚扰研讨会，强制出席。上午10点，服装试穿，服装车。
from Kent Subornak. That said, hey all, for this Friday, August 3rd, here's our schedule for the day. 8.45 AM. Check in with the NBC Universal Studios harassment seminar. This will be located on stage 3. 9 AM, harassment seminar, mandatory attendance. 10 AM, costume fittings, wardrobe trailer.
上午11点，剧本围读，编剧车里的fun run（慈善赛跑）这一集。中午演员体检。邮件到这里就结束了吗？如有任何问题请致电，肯。哦，就这样。就这样。我还以为，首先，我觉得这是一个有趣的视角，你可以看到我们在筹备一集节目时的一天是怎么度过的。
11 AM, table read, episode episode fun run in the writers trailer. Noon cast physicals. Is that the end of the email? Please call if you have any questions, Kent. Oh, that's it. That's it. I thought it was, first of all, I thought this was an interesting perspective that you saw what a day would be like as we prep an episode.
这是你情绪的铺垫，就像——你想知道你在做什么吗？我猜我只是没想到答案会是去参加性骚扰研讨会和体检。我的意思是，我只是觉得——不，我当时在干嘛？我等不及要知道了。我的意思是，我要说的是，如果瓶子里的精灵给我一个愿望，我绝不会重新选择这一天。好吧，好吧。好吧，我只是觉得这是一个非常有趣的视角。A，它展示了我们开始新一季所必须做的事情，
It is your build up to like, would you like to know what you were doing? I guess I just wasn't expecting the answer to be you attended a harassment seminar and got a physical. I mean, I just thought like, no, what was I doing? I can't wait to find out. I mean, I have to say I wouldn't pick this day to redo if a genie in a bottle ever gave me a wish. Okay, okay. Well, I just thought this was a very interesting perspective. A, it shows what we had to do to start a new season
B，我们在8月份拍摄了《慈善赛跑》第一部分和第二部分。好吧，这一集的这部分我们在室内，但各位，我们要去室外跑步。现在是8月。我只是觉得，我只是觉得这是一个有趣的视角，詹娜。我很喜欢。太棒了。我只是以为你要告诉我一些更刺激的事情。
and also B, we filmed Fun Run, part one and part two in August. Okay, this part of the episode were inside, but folks, we're gonna be running outside. It's August. I just think, I just think it's an interesting perspective, Jenna. I love it. It's great. I just thought you were gonna let me in on something more exciting.
就这些。然后是我的演员体检。以为你要告诉我一些更刺激的事情。就这些。然后是我的演员体检。我不知道，还有我的服装试穿。好吧，我很兴奋。显然，我很兴奋能找到肯发来的这封邮件。好吧，我很高兴你留着它，因为这值得珍藏。哦，闭上你的嘴。
That's all. Then my cast physical. thought you were gonna let me in on something more exciting. That's all. Then my cast physical. I don't know, and my wardrobe fitting. Well, I was very excited. Clearly, I was very excited to find this email from Kent. Well, I'm glad you saved it because that's a keeper. Oh, shut your mouth.
你也闭嘴。你也闭嘴。把它记进书里。你也闭嘴。德怀特会怎么说？闭上你的嘴。我可能把那封邮件删了，因为我喜欢保持收件箱整洁。我很庆幸你留着它，我觉得。
You shut it. You shut it. Grab book that. You shut it. What would Dwight say? Zip your lid. I probably deleted that email because I like to keep it tidy in box. I love that you saved it, I think.
噗。我不知道该说什么。我不知道该怎么过渡到这一集。不如我们开始聊这一集吧？好的，我们从迈克尔吃麦片开始。是的。在第9秒时，我的背景注意了，各位，你可以看到那个红色的锅状篮子，那是詹娜离开总公司时从她的箱子里掉出来的东西。不，你在开玩笑吧。它就放在那儿。哦，天哪，我太喜欢这个细节了。是的，她把她的东西摆在公寓周围。好吧，
Pfft. I don't know what to say. I don't know how to segue to the episode. How about we get into this episode? Alright, we start off with Michael eating some cereal. Yeah. And at nine seconds, my background folks, you can see that red pot basket thing that fell out of Jan's box as she was leaving corporate. No, you're kidding me. It's sitting right there. Oh my gosh, I love that so much. Yeah, she's put her things around the condo. Well,
我们在这一幕中收到了来自汉娜·A、罗伯特·F、克里斯蒂娜·J、阿德里安·吉布斯、切尔西·沃伦以及许多其他写信来的粉丝的彩蛋发现，他们说迈克尔在吃韦格曼斯（Wegmans）的麦片。韦格曼斯是东海岸的一家本地杂货店。他们想知道是谁的主意要在剧中特写这些韦格曼斯的产品的？那是菲尔·谢伊。是的，我刚想说这肯定是菲尔·谢伊。他在做这种调研方面总是那么厉害。但菲尔·谢伊到底是怎么弄到韦格曼斯葡萄干麸皮麦片和韦格曼斯豆奶的？我完全不知道。
we had a big fan catch at this moment from Hannah A. Robert F. Christine J. Adrian Gibbs, Chelsea Warren, and many others who wrote in to say that Michael is eating cereal from Wegmans. And Wegmans is a local East Coast grocery store. They wanted to know whose idea was it to feature these Wegmans products. That would be Phil Shea. Yeah, I was gonna say how to be Phil Shea. He was so great about doing that kind of research. But how in the world did Phil Shea get Wegmans rais raisin brand and Wegman's soy milk I have no idea.
我很佩服。听着，菲尔·谢伊就是那种“上面有人”的家伙。他有路子。菲尔·谢伊有人。他在斯克兰顿有内线，会去斯克兰顿的韦格曼斯购买，顺便说一句，我查了一下，它一周七天营业，从早上6点到午夜，位于科尔特斯泉路1315号。就是这样，各位。如果你想吃迈克尔正在吃的葡萄干麸皮麦片，去那里就能买到。把它加入你的邓德米夫林斯克兰顿观光之旅中。没错。好吧，然后迈克尔走进卧室，发现简还在睡觉。
I'm impressed. Listen, Phil Shea is the guy that knows a guy. He's got a guy. Phil Shea's got a guy. He's got a guy on the ground and scranten going to the Wegmans and Scranten, which by the way, I looked it up as open seven days a week from 6 a.m. to midnight and is located at 1315 Colts Spring Road. There you go, folks. If you want to eat the raisin brand that Michael is eating, that's where you can get it. Add it to your dundermiflin Scranton tour. Exactly. Well, then Michael enters the bedroom to reveal that Jan is still sleeping.
她可能还要再睡几个小时，他说。在这个镜头里你真的能看到她对这个公寓做了什么。我的意思是，她设置了一个梳妆台。有一个巨大的镜子。还有一个衣架。我看到两个高大无比的烛台。有一把粉红色的椅子，但你猜怎么着？有一把粉红色的椅子，但你猜怎么着，没有的是——
She's probably going to sleep for another few hours, he says. You can really see what she's doing to the condo in this. I mean, she has set up a vanity. There's a giant mirror. There's a clothes rack. I see two tall, enormous candle things. There's a pink chair, but guess what? There's a pink chair, but guess what, there's not.
好吧，迈克尔在晚宴派对结尾时睡的那张小床，在床尾。床尾供他睡觉的长凳现在还不在那里。我也注意到了这一点。好吧，也许哪天我会给你发封电子邮件聊聊这个。也许肯给我们发了一封邮件。你可以删掉它，因为你喜欢整洁的收件箱。哦，天哪，你因为这封邮件的事情生我的气，但是，当你回听时，
Well, Michael's little bed that he sleeps on during dinner party at the end of the bed. The bench at the foot of the bed that he says he sleeps on is not there yet. I noticed that as well. Well, maybe I'll email you about it someday. Maybe Kent sent us an email. You can delete it because you like a tidy box. Oh my gosh, you're so mad at me about this email thing, but I like, when you listen back,
当你回听时，安吉拉，我想让你听听你当时营造的那种期待感。我是这样为你还原的。我找到了一封邮件，它会告诉你这周你在做什么。我有。我要告诉你。然后你的反应是：我可以用我的一些邮件把你彻底铲平。而我的反应是：她会说什么？
when you listen back, Angela, I want you to hear like the anticipation that you built. This is how I'm gonna do it for you. I have an email that I found that is gonna tell you what you were doing this week. I have it. I'm gonna tell you. And then you were like, I could burn you to the ground with some of my emails. And I'm like, what is she gonna say?
我说，你说，上午8点45分。报到参加性骚扰研讨会。然后我的反应是，等等，什么？等等。事情走向变成这样了。等等。你说，哦，我该害怕吗？我说，不。
I said you said, you say 8.45 AM. Check in for sexual harassment seminar. And I was like, wait, what? Hold up. That's where this is going. Hold up. You said, ooh, should I be scared? And I said, no.
我的意思是，我有些邮件可以把一切铲平。你也有，但这封显然不是。显然不是这封。显然不是这封。这周你很配合你的工作及其要求。好吧，你的新外号是“整洁箱”。好好享受吧。你知道那是阴道的另一个词吗。
I mean, I have the ones that can burn it down. So do you, but not this one. Clearly not this one. Clearly not this one. This week you complied with your job and its requirements. Well, your new nickname is Tidybox. Enjoy. You know that's another word for vagina.
我知道。因此是个双关语。那个一直这么说吗？哦，天哪。整洁箱。好吧。我们？我们怎么了？
I know. Hence the double-ontonger. Did that always say that? Oh, good lord. Tiny bucks. Okay. We? What's happened to us?
好吧，我们做朋友很久了。事情就是这样。好的，我喜欢。现在迈克尔在车里，他很兴奋，伙计们。他有一个单人访谈镜头。他觉得这将是美好的一年。简在家。
Well, we've been friends a long time. That's what's happened. All right. I love it. While Michael's in his car now, he's excited you guys. He has a talking head. He thinks it's gonna be a good year. Jan is home.
吉姆回来了，瑞安在总公司，安迪和德怀特在销售团队大放异彩。他觉得自己很受眷顾。确实如此。他也正在分心。然后——砰！当他开车撞到梅雷迪思时——我们跟凯特聊过这个。以这种方式开始这一季真是太棒、太刺激了。我不得不说。我重看的时候甚至都很惊讶。我想，哦天哪。好吧，还记得在采访中凯特说她的第一反应是，哦天哪，梅雷迪思还活着吗？她听说有些编剧曾提议把梅雷迪思写死。你知道他们是谁吗？我查清了。
Jim is back. Ryan is at corporate, Andy and Dwight are rocking the sales team. He feels blessed. He does. He also is not paying attention. And then bam! When he hits Meredith with his car and we talked about this with Kate. What an amazing and exciting way to start the season. I have to say. I was surprised even when I rewatched it. I was like, oh God. Well, remember in her interview when Kate said that her first thought was, oh my gosh, just Meredith lived. And she heard that maybe there were some writers who had pitched that they kill Meredith. Do you know who they were? I got to the bottom of it. Oh no, this is probably a better email. I was emailing with Greg Daniels and Justin Spitzer and they told me that yes, they spent one evening pitching on
哦不，这可能是一封更好的邮件。我当时在和格雷格·丹尼尔斯以及贾斯廷·斯皮策发邮件，他们告诉我，是的，他们花了一个晚上的时间讨论这个想法：也许梅雷迪思死了，但不仅如此。不仅是梅雷迪思死了。什么？格雷格告诉我，首先，这个想法是他们会把这拍成一个偷拍镜头。所以迈克尔的车里不会有摄像机。这只会是他开车上班时的偷拍镜头，并配上旁白形式的单人访谈。好吧。
this idea that maybe Meredith died but it's more than that. It's not just that Meredith died. What? Greg told me that first of all, the idea was that they would shoot this as a spy shot. So they would not have a camera inside the car with Michael. It would just be a spy shot of him arriving at work for the day with the talking head as a voiceover. Okay. He said that the pitch was that Michael would accidentally hit Meredith with this car and then thinking that no one could see him. He didn't want to leave
他说，当时的构思是迈克尔不小心开车撞了梅雷迪思，然后以为没有人看见他。他不想留下
any witnesses. And so in one pitch, he backed over her to make sure she was dead. Oh, good Lord. And then Justin told me that there was a pitch that Michael would go into his trunk and get one of those anti-theft devices called the club, and then club her to death, and then hide her body. Were they on drugs? Were they on drugs? I mean, seriously, that is the end of the show!
任何目击证人。所以在其中一个构思里，他倒车从她身上碾过去，确保她死透了。哦，天哪。然后贾斯廷告诉我，曾有一个构思是迈克尔去后备箱拿那种叫“方向盘锁”的防盗装置，然后把她活活打死，再藏起尸体。他们嗑药了吗？他们嗑药了吗？我是说，说真的，那是这部剧的结局啊！
There's no coming back! What were they thinking? That's what Greg said. Greg said, of course, we could never do this, but it was a pitch that was discussed for some time, and he said there were a few writers who were fighting for it. They were fighting for Michael to accidentally and then purposely do Meredith in. I need names. He wouldn't give me the names. I need names because I need to do a mental check on them. Holy cow. So yeah, that's what I found out. There was a moment where they were pitching that maybe Meredith doesn't make it. How craziness.
这根本无法收场！他们在想什么？格雷格就是这么说的。格雷格说，当然，我们绝对不能这么做，但这确实是讨论了一段时间的一个构思，他说有几个编剧极力争取这个方案。他们极力争取让迈克尔先是不小心，然后故意做掉梅雷迪思。我需要知道名字。他没有给我名字。我需要名字，因为我得对他们进行一次心理评估。我的天啊。所以，是的，这就是我发现的。曾有一段时间，他们在构思也许梅雷迪思没挺过去。太疯狂了。
craziness also, I definitely don't want to know any of their late night pitches on Angela. Okay, thanks, okay. All right, well, let's get into this episode. There's a into this episode. There's a lot to discuss. We start out with Jim and Pam talking to the IT guy because Pam crashed the computers looking for some celebrity sex tape.
太疯狂了。另外，我绝对不想知道安吉拉任何关于他们深夜构思的点子。好吧，谢谢，好吧。好吧，让我们进入这一集。这里有很多内容要讨论。我们从吉姆和帕姆与IT人员的对话开始，因为帕姆为了找某些名人的性爱录像把电脑搞崩溃了。
Yeah. We got a lot of mail about this. I did a little bit of a mini deep dive. Well, let's see. Lydia Lind, Megan Harrison, Mary Newberry and Chris Roa all wrote in to say, it seems out of character for Pam to purchase a celebrity sex tape. Did your script say whose celebrity sex tape Pam clicked on or did you ever come up with your own idea of who it might be? Okay Jenna, I think I know what the writers were hinting at here because I googled, by the way, be careful googling this, I googled celebrity sex tape 2007. Yes. And the first thing that comes up is Kim Kardashian and her boyfriend were vacationing and made a video.
是的。我们收到了很多关于这部分的邮件。我做了一个小小的深度挖掘。好吧，让我们看看。莉迪亚·林德、梅根·哈里森、玛丽·纽伯里和克里斯·罗亚都写信说，帕姆去购买名人的性爱录像似乎不符合她的性格。你们的剧本里有没有写明帕姆点击的是哪个名人的性爱录像，或者你们有没有自己想过这可能是谁？好吧，詹娜，我想我知道编剧在这里暗示的是什么，因为我谷歌了一下——顺便说一句，谷歌这个的时候要小心——我谷歌了“2007年名人性爱录像”。是的。弹出的第一条是金·卡戴珊和她的男友在度假时拍了一段视频。
And that got leaked and it was released March of 2007. And there was a ton of like chatter, you know, just everyone was talking about it, right? And I think when the writers thought of this story idea, that's what they were thinking of. I don't have proof of that, but this was written in around June of 2007 and that had happened in March. Yeah, so it was in the zeitgeist. But I don't think Pam would click on that. Like is she- I don't think Pam would click it in here. Maybe she's just trying to be coy or- I don't know. Or to hear something. It definitely shocked me when she said it. And also she said, work, she's at front reception, she's going to watch this.
那个视频泄露了，并在2007年3月发布。当时有大量的八卦闲聊，你知道的，每个人都在谈论它，对吧？我想当编剧们想到这个情节创意时，他们想的就是这个。我没有证据，但这大约是在2007年6月写的，而那件事发生在3月。是的，所以这当时是流行文化热点。但我不认为帕姆会点那个。比如她——我不认为帕姆会点这个。也许她只是想装作害羞或者——我不知道。或者只是想听听八卦。当她说出来的时候确实震惊到我了。而且她说，在工作，她在前台接待处，她要看这个。
Yeah. She shut down the whole computer grid. I don't know. It was a little bit of a stretch for me when I watched it too. I agree. Okay. Well, now Jim has a talking head. He talks about how he broke up with Karen and it was really awkward because she came back
是的。她把整个电脑网都搞瘫痪了。我不知道。当我看到这一段时，我觉得有点牵强。我同意。好吧，现在吉姆有一个单人访谈。他谈到他和凯伦分手了，这真的很尴尬，因为她回来了，
and she said she wasn't going anywhere. And you can see Karen is letting him have it. They're in the kitchen. And as they're going at it, Phyllis and Angela shoot Pam a very judgy look. Yeah, two minutes, 10 seconds. Judgy, Phyllis and Angela, oh my gosh. Phyllis and Angela combo sass. Com Phyllis, Angela, combo, Sass.
并且她说她哪儿也不去。你可以看到凯伦在给他好看。他们在厨房里。当他们争论时，菲利斯和安吉拉给了帕姆一个非常严厉评判的眼神。是的，两分十秒。评判，菲利斯和安吉拉，哦，天哪。菲利斯和安吉拉组合毒舌。组合，菲利斯，安吉拉，组合，毒舌。
Combo, Sass! That's a lot of Sass. And, but he said, you know, Karen said she wasn't going anywhere, but then the next day her desk was cleared off, and he's single and looking. Yeah. He wrapped that up quickly. You know, this was a highly anticipated episode
组合，毒舌！那可是相当毒舌。而且，但是他说，你知道的，凯伦说她哪儿也不去，但第二天她的办公桌就被清空了，而他是单身且在寻找对象。是的。他很快就把这个话题结束了。你知道的，这曾是备受期待的一集，
because we had this big cliffhanger from the last season of Jim asking Pam on a date. And here now Jim's saying he's single. Pam has a talking head where she says, oh yeah, we went to dinner a few times. We talked through his breakup, but we're just good friends and it's really nice to be friends again. Well, I'm with Kevin. I'm with Kevin. Are you kidding me? Yeah, Kevin's not having it. This was also a fun talking head for Kevin and Oscar
因为上一季结尾时吉姆约帕姆出去约会，留下了巨大的悬念。而现在吉姆说他是单身。帕姆有一个单人访谈，她说，哦，对，我们一起吃了几次饭。我们聊了聊他的分手，但我们只是好朋友，能重新做回朋友感觉真好。好吧，我站凯文。我站凯文。你在开玩笑吗？是的，凯文可不买账。这也是凯文和奥斯卡的一个有趣的单人访谈，
because it starts with Kevin and then reveals Oscar when Kevin's like, right? And he's like, well, there's no evidence of intimacy. You know, but they are both in very good moods. We had a couple of fan questions about this plot point. Okay. Julia Johnson and Madeline Nelson noticed, Pam has a big change to her hair and wardrobe. Is it because she's stating Jim now?
因为它是从凯文开始，然后当凯文说“对吧？”时露出了奥斯卡，而奥斯卡说，嗯，没有任何亲密的证据。你知道，但他们两个人的心情都非常好。关于这个情节，我们有几个粉丝提问。好的。茱莉亚·约翰逊和玛德琳·纳尔逊注意到，帕姆的发型和服装有了很大的改变。是因为她现在在和吉姆约会吗？
And was there a lot of discussion about these changes? Oh yes. Well, her hair is very different. Yes, no more clipped back hair, crunchy hair. Yes, this change was a huge discussion. Pam is also not wearing her traditional button down shirt and her little cardigan. She's wearing this cutesy little sweater
大家对这些改变讨论很多吗？哦，是的。嗯，她的头发大不一样了。是的，不再是夹在脑后、那种硬邦邦的头发了。是的，这个改变引发了巨大的讨论。帕姆也没有穿她传统的扣领衬衫和她的小开衫。她穿着这件可爱的小毛衣
with a little kind of bow that ties on the side. A very, very flirtatious shade of beige. I noticed that too. I was like, well, we didn't go too far. Yeah. Get me the cutest beige sweater you can find. Well, it was a big discussion. We couldn't have this giant transformation. Greg did not want that moment from those movies where the sort of nerdy girl with the glasses falls in love and then after she falls in love She's got a gorgeous blowout and doesn't need her glasses anymore You know that whole story that we saw a million times growing up. Mm-hmm. It was called Kelly Kapoor
带着一个小小的、在侧边系成蝴蝶结的领带。一种非常非常调情的米色。我也注意到了。我当时想，好吧，我们还没走得太远。是的。给我找一件你能找到的最可爱的米色毛衣。嗯，这是一个很大的讨论。我们不能有那种巨大的转变。格莱格不希望有那些电影里的时刻，那种戴着眼镜的书呆子女孩坠入爱河，然后在她坠入爱河之后，她有了一个华丽的吹风造型，不再需要眼镜了，你知道那种我们在成长过程中看过一百万次的故事。嗯。它叫凯利·卡普尔
It was called Kelly Kapoor You can only do that with one character. So we met our limit. But we did imagine that this new relationship would possibly affect him and how she looked and her desire to make an effort that maybe she didn't have a desire to make before. I get this. I mean, don't you remember Angela in your young love phases with someone new that you're dating? You give a little extra juzh, right? Yeah, of course. We had a big fan catch regarding Pam's wardrobe. This came from Megan Robinson, Steph Baldwin, Laura Rollden, Haley McMurdy, and Kelly and
它叫凯利·卡普尔你只能对一个角色这样做。所以我们达到了极限。但我们确实想象，这段新恋情可能会影响到他、她的外表以及她想要做出努力的愿望，而这种愿望可能是她以前没有的。我懂这个。我是说，难道你不记得安吉拉在你和新约会对象处于年轻热恋阶段的时候吗？你会稍微打扮一下，对吧？对，当然。关于帕姆的服装，我们有一个很大的粉丝发现。这来自梅根·罗宾逊、斯蒂夫·鲍德温、劳拉·罗尔登、海莉·麦克默迪以及凯利和
Mim. They all noticed that Pam's necklace changes in this episode. You know what it is now? What? She's a butterfly. Fly, butterfly! You're not that warm anymore! Fly!
米姆。他们都注意到帕姆的项链在这个集里换了。你知道现在是什么吗？什么？她是一只蝴蝶。飞吧，蝴蝶！你再也不是那么温暖了！飞吧！
No! I think you mean caterpillar. Caterpillar? Squishy thing! You're not that squit. You're a beautiful flying in the wind. Yes, she has metamorphosized. Yeah.
不！我想你是说毛毛虫。毛毛虫？软绵绵的东西！你不是那么软……你是一只在风中美丽飞翔的动物。是的，她蜕变了。是的。
Into a beautiful butterfly. That's right. No longer the unicorn. Now the butterfly. Jim and Pam at three minutes are discussing their separate weekend plans in front of Kevin. It's making him crazy, right? Because he's not buying it. Yeah. Pam says, you know, maybe she'll go to the flea market at the drive-in. Guys, I'll look this up. There is a flea market at an old drive-in and it was actually the Reader's Choice Award for Best Flea Market. It's located at the famous Circle Drive-in in the Circle Flea Fair. It's the largest flea market and farmers
变成了一只美丽的蝴蝶。没错。不再是独角兽了。现在是蝴蝶。吉姆和帕姆在三分时正在凯文面前讨论他们各自的周末计划。这让他快疯了，对吧？因为他根本不买账。Yeah. 帕姆说，你知道的，也许她会去汽车影院的跳蚤市场。伙计们，我查过了。在一个旧的汽车影院确实有一个跳蚤市场，它实际上是读者选择奖的最佳跳蚤市场。它位于著名的环形汽车影院和环形跳蚤集市。它是东北宾夕法尼亚州最大的跳蚤市场和农夫
market in Northeastern Pennsylvania. So that is 100% believable that Pam would be going. Yes. And Jim says he's going to go mountain biking at Montage Mountain. Well, I look that up. And correct me if I'm wrong, folks in Pennsylvania. But Montage Mountain has ski runs, but you can't mountain bike on it. And unless there's some trails I don't know about, I actually found an online petition from April of 2019 of folks wanting to mountain bike on montage mountain, but you can't. And there's an online petition because people want to. Wow. Sorry. Sorry. Had to do a local deep dive. How to do a local deep dive. Well, you know what? Perhaps that's the evidence that Jim and Pam are not actually having separate plans that weekend.
市场。所以帕姆会去那里是百分之百可信的。是的。吉姆说他要去蒙太奇山骑山地自行车。嗯，我查了一下。如果我错了，请宾夕法尼亚的朋友们纠正我。但蒙太奇山有滑雪道，你却不能在上面骑山地自行车。除非有什么我不知道的小径，我实际上在2019年4月发现了一份请愿书，是人们想要在蒙太奇山上骑山地自行车，但你不能。而且还有一份在线请愿书，因为人们想要这么做。哇。抱歉。抱歉。不得不做一次本地深度挖掘。不得不做一次本地深度挖掘。好吧，你知道吗？也许这就是证明吉姆和帕姆那个周末其实并没有各自的计划。
Cause he would know if Kevin knew that there was no mountain biking on Montage Mountain, he would know. Kevin doesn't know that cause he's not athletic. He doesn't know. But Jim knows that. That's right. Jim got it wrong. Well, now Michael arrives and he breaks the news that Maritath has been hit by a car.
因为他会知道，如果凯文知道蒙太奇山上没有山地自行车，他就会知道。凯文不知道那是因为他不运动。他不知道。但吉姆知道。没错。吉姆猜错了。好吧，现在迈克尔来了，他带来了一个消息：梅丽塔被车撞了。
Yeah. Yeah. You know, luckily he was there. Yeah. And he drove her to the hospital. He said the doctors did the best they could. They did everything they could to save her life. And she's going to be okay. Yeah. And Stanley's like, why the hell would you say it like that?
是的。是的。你知道，幸亏他在那里。是的。他把她送到了医院。他说医生们已经尽力了。他们尽了一切努力来挽救她的生命。她会没事的。是的。斯坦利说，你为什么要用这种方式说话？
Who talks like that? It's so good. I love that line from Stanley so much. Leslie is so good in that delivery. He's so good. And I loved it when Andy's like, well, who hit her? And then Michael's like, kind of a good news, bad news there. I was able to be on the scene so quickly because I was in the car that hit her and Jim's like oh no. Yeah, Jim's like who was driving the car? And that's what Pam is like. Oh my god. Oh my god. At four minutes, four seconds,
谁会这么说话？太棒了。我太喜欢斯坦利的那句台词了。莱斯利在这段台词的演绎上太棒了。他太棒了。我喜欢安迪说“谁撞了她”的时候，然后迈克尔说，这有点算是个好消息坏消息吧。我能这么快赶到现场是因为我坐在撞她的车里，吉姆说哦不。是的，吉姆说谁在开车？这就是帕姆的反应。我的天啊。我的天啊。在四分钟四秒时，
there's a reaction shot of everyone and the accountants are all sort of standing together. shot of everyone and the accountants are all sort of standing together. Guys, the return of the Fluffy Blouse! Oh, is it a Fluffy Blouse in an accountant stack? It's a Fluffy Blouse in an accountant clump. This is more of a clump than a stack. All right, but Jenna, you can also see that over the summer I got bangs. Oh! Yes, and Kim Fairy had to try to style my hair, but I think I have sort of stylish bangs. Oh, yeah. Well, there you go. I know. Well, now we are moving into Michael's office. Dwight is trying to make Michael feel better by explaining. It's going to be fine. I mean, it's only Meredith. But Michael is upset because he thinks everyone thinks he might be a murderer.
有一个大家的反应镜头，会计们都站在一起。大家的反应镜头，会计们都站在一起。伙计们，蓬松衬衫回归了！哦，这是会计堆里的一件蓬松衬衫吗？这是会计堆里的一件蓬松衬衫。这与其说是一堆，不如说是一群。好吧，但是珍娜，你也可以看到整个夏天我剪了刘海。哦！是的，金·费瑞不得不试着给我弄我的发型，但我认为我有种时髦的刘海。哦，是的。好吧，给你。我知道。好吧，现在我们要走进迈克尔的办公室。德怀特正试图通过解释来让迈克尔感觉好点。一切都会好起来的。我是说，这只是梅丽塔。但迈克尔很难过，因为他觉得每个人都认为他可能是个杀人犯。
Or they were looking at him like he was a murderer. Can you imagine if some of the writers had had their way? I know, no kidding. Gosh. Well, now Pam is gonna go around the office. She thinks everyone should visit Meredith and she's collecting money so they can buy her flowers. Yes, but Angela says she can't go because sprinkles is sick. Mm-hmm. And Angela needs to go
或者他们看着他的眼神就像他是个杀人犯。你能想象如果有些编剧得逞的话会怎样吗？我知道，不开玩笑。天哪。好吧，现在帕姆要在办公室里走一圈。她认为每个人都应该去看看梅丽塔，她在筹集资金以便他们能给她买花。是的，但安吉拉说她不能去，因为斯普林克尔斯生病了。嗯。安吉拉需要去
home at lunch to give sprinkles some medicine and eat lunch with her cat. Yeah. And you guys, there are wonderful deleted talking heads from this episode. So many characters have great talking heads, but this is a talking head that would have happened right before Pam walked over to Angela, and I have to read it too, because it's so fun to me. Angela has a talking head that says, I've had sprinkles for 16 years. I adopted her when I graduated from accounting school. I knew the kind of life I wanted. One with the companionship and unpredictable good times only a cat offers. Hmm. The unpredictable good times a cat offers. You know, cats really do offer unpredictable good times.
午饭回家给斯普林克尔斯喂药并和她的猫一起吃午饭。是的。伙计们，这一集里有精彩的被删掉的访谈片段。许多角色都有很棒的访谈片段，但这是一个本来会发生在帕姆走到安吉拉面前之前的访谈片段，我也必须读一下，因为它对我来说太有趣了。安吉拉有一个访谈片段说，我养斯普林克尔斯16年了。我从会计学校毕业时收养了它。我知道我想过什么样的生活。一种只有猫才能提供的陪伴和不可预测的美好时光的生活。嗯。猫提供不可预测的美好时光。你知道，猫确实能提供不可预测的美好时光。
Creed Bratton has texted me this sentence. An unpredictable good time only a cat offers. Creed texted me that the other day. I love that. So, yes. So Angela has that talking head and that you didn't get to see. And it really sort of builds up like, this is like more than a cat to her. I mean, we already know that.
克里德·布拉顿给我发了这句话。只有猫才能提供的不可预测的美好时光。克里德前几天给我发了这个。我喜欢这个。所以，是的。安吉拉有那个你没能看到的访谈片段。它真的有点像……这比一只猫对她来说更重要。我是说，我们已经知道了。
But when Pam suggests that Angela, like, should go and that she's like ditching on her party planning committee duties, Angela's ticked. Uh, Sam, can I get a Pam Sass? Pam Sass! Yeah. We had some people write in, Paige Banker, Lauren Corwin. They just wrote in all caps, major Pam Sass at five minutes, 35 seconds. Yeah, I agree, you guys.
但当帕姆建议安吉拉应该去，而且她好像在逃避她的派对策划委员会职责时，安吉拉气坏了。呃，萨姆，我能来点帕姆式的讽刺吗？帕姆式的讽刺！是的。我们有一些人写信来，佩奇·班克尔、劳伦·科尔温。他们直接用大写字母写道，在五分三十五秒时有严重的帕姆式讽刺。是的，我同意，伙计们。
Pam, Pam says, can't your other cats keep her company? And Angela's like, there's bad blood, jealousies, clicks. What's happening at this woman's house? Um, I have to tell you something about this scene. This was what I thought you were going to tell me when you said that I had written you an email about this episode. Why? And about what I was doing this week.
帕姆，帕姆说，你的其他猫不能陪她吗？安吉拉说，有宿怨、嫉妒、小团体。这个女人的家里到底在发生什么？嗯，关于这个场景我必须告诉你一件事。这就是我以为你要告诉我的事，当你告诉我说我曾就这一集给你写过电子邮件时。为什么？以及我这周在做什么。
Why? Lady, I was really, really hung over when we shot this scene. Like, super hung over. And if you look at me in this scene compared to every other scene, you can see it on my face. I am like, I am gray, I'm kind of green. Why? My eyes are puffy. I will never forget it. So, the night before this shoot, I went to a Mexican restaurant and I was with a friend who ordered a margarita. Okay. I had never really had a margarita before. Oh, no way. Yes, yes, it's true. I, we've talked about this. I did not have a lot of experience with drinking.
为什么？大姐，我们拍这场戏的时候我宿醉得非常非常厉害。就像，超级宿醉。如果你看这场戏里我和其他每一场戏的对比，你就能从我的脸上看出来。我看起来就像……我是灰色的，有点发绿。为什么？我的眼睛肿了。我永远不会忘记。所以，在这场戏开拍的前一天晚上，我去了一家墨西哥餐厅，我和一个朋友一起，她点了一杯玛格丽塔。好吧。我以前从来没喝过玛格丽塔。哦，不会吧。是的，是的，这是真的。我，我们谈过这个。我没有太多喝酒的经验。
I just, you know, I had a cosmopolitan. I had to research drinking in order to play drunk pym. So I took a sip of it. Yeah. And I was like, this is delicious. I love this drink. Uh-oh. And then was like, this is delicious. I love this drink. Uh-oh. And then I had three.
我只是，你知道，我喝过大都会。为了扮演喝醉的皮姆，我不得不研究喝酒。所以我抿了一口。是的。然后我想，这太好喝了。我喜欢这杯酒。哦哦。然后就觉得，这太好喝了。我喜欢这杯酒。哦哦。然后我喝了三杯。
Three? Three. Over the course of the dinner. Jenna. I then, you know, lady, this scene was the first scene of the next day. We had a super early call time and I was really feeling it. Like I didn't, I had not had enough time to recover from my three margaritas.
三杯？三杯。在晚餐的过程中。珍娜。然后我，你知道，大姐，这场戏是第二天早上的第一场戏。我们的通告时间超级早，我真的感觉到了。就像我没有，我没有足够的时间从我的三杯玛格丽塔酒中恢复过来。
Oh yeah, Michael Times were routinely like 5am, 5.30. So you were sweating to Kila. I was. And so I thought when you said earlier that you had an email from me about what I was doing this week I was like oh my gosh did I write Angela about those margaritas? Sorry to disappoint you had a mandatory physical, table read, and a sexual harassment seminar. Exactly. Anyway, that's my little that's my little tidbit every time I see this scene.
哦是的，迈克尔的时间通常是早上5点，5点半。所以你在出龙舌兰酒的汗。我是。所以我以为你刚才说你有一封来自我的邮件，关于我这周在做什么的时候，我在想，哦天哪，我是不是写信给安吉拉说了那些玛格丽塔酒？抱歉让你失望了，你有一场强制性的体检、剧本围读和一个性骚扰研讨会。没错。总之，这就是我的小……每当我看到这个场景时我的小花絮。
I'm reminded of the night that I first drank three margaritas. Well now I'll always remember it. So now Michael has to call Ryan because Ryan is his boss and tell him he hit Meredith on company property. And... With his company car. Yeah. And Ryan is such a badass boss in this.
我想起了我第一次喝三杯玛格丽塔酒的那个夜晚。好吧，现在我永远都会记得了。所以现在迈克尔必须给瑞安打电话，因为瑞安是他的老板，告诉他他在公司财产上撞了梅丽塔。而且……用他的公司车。是的。瑞安在这集里是一个非常强硬的老板。
He's clearly, he's like and be in the boss and talking to Michael this way. Well, and then we go to the Ryan talking head. And Ryan has a new look. He's got his like, what do you call that? It's not a beard. It's like a permanent stubble. Yeah, it's like a five o'clock shadow,
他显然，他是那种……作为老板并以这种方式跟迈克尔说话。嗯，然后我们来到了瑞安的访谈片段。瑞安有了一个新造型。他留着那种……你叫那个什么？那不是胡子。就像是永久的胡茬。是的，就像是下午五点的胡影，
but it's a choice. It's a choice. Yeah. Yeah, and his hair's all slicked back. He's got like kind of a Gordon Gecko thing going on. Yeah, he looks like he should be in the show succession. That's what he looks like. Yes, right?
但这是一种选择。这是一种选择。是的。是的，他的头发全部向后梳。他有点像戈登·盖柯的感觉。是的，他看起来应该去演《继承之战》这部剧。这就是他看起来的样子。是的，对吧？
And he has the same kind of like cheesy attitude. He's like, some people keep calling me, you know, wonder kid, you know, not really sure what that means. And well, I guess I do know what it means. He's, oh, it's so cringy. Yeah, it's great. This is, we're going to get a glimpse now of what this new dynamic is going to be like. Well, then we have a scene that I love, Angela,
而且他有一种同样俗气的态度。他说，有些人一直叫我，你知道，神童，你知道，不太确定那是什么意思。好吧，我想我知道那是什么意思。他，哦，太让人脚趾抠地了。是的，太棒了。这是，我们现在将一窥这种新动态会是什么样子。好吧，然后我们有一个我非常喜欢的场景，安吉拉，
because it's a Dwighton Angela secret scene. Remember the people in the office, we don't know you're dating, right? So you guys are still kind of like a secret couple. Whenever you want to talk to each other, you have to go be like weirdly secretive about it. Yeah. I mean, I guess only Jim knows, right? And Pam. And Pam. Have Jim and Pam hopefully talked about it at this point.
因为这是一个德怀特和安吉拉的秘密场景。记住办公室里的人，我们不知道你们在约会，对吧？所以你们俩仍然有点像秘密情侣。每当你们想和对方说话时，你们都得表现得像个诡异的秘密一样。是的。我是说，我猜只有吉姆知道，对吧？还有帕姆。还有帕姆。吉姆和帕姆希望在这个时候已经谈过这件事了吗？
We still don't know. You would think. So lady, I had a long speech where I talk about all of Sprinkle's medications and I did that thing like you did on beach games. I learned it backwards and forwards so that I could say it just effortlessly, you know. But here it is. Sam, can you play that clip? So what do you need me to do? I wrote it out. There's a diabetes shot. Roll the insulin in your hands. Don't shake it. She gets an ACE inhibitor with her meal. You have to put her right in front of the dish or she won't see it because of the cataracts. Mixed one capsule of Omega fatty acid in with her kidney medicine. And you want to give that to her 15 minutes after she's eaten. And oh, there's a fungal cream because she has this infection under her tail.
我们还是不知道。你本来会这么想的。所以大姐，我有一长段台词，讲的是斯普林克尔斯的所有药物，我做了像你在海滩游戏里做的那样。我把它正着反着都背熟了，这样我就可以不费力气地说出来，你知道的。但就是这样。萨姆，你能播放那个片段吗？那么你需要我做什么？我写下来了。有一个糖尿病针剂。把胰岛素在手里滚动。不要摇晃它。她吃饭时要吃一种血管紧张素转化酶抑制剂。你必须把她直接放在盘子前面，否则由于白内障她看不见。把一粒欧米茄脂肪酸胶囊混进她的肾病药里。你要在她吃完饭15分钟后给她吃那个。哦，还有一种真菌霜，因为她的尾巴底下有感染。
So you're going to have to lift her tail and put the cream right at the base of her tail. I love that you memorized it, Angela, because when I watched that, I wondered. I thought the answer was yes, because you delivered it like you knew. And if you had a cat that was sick, you would know right? Yeah, I wouldn't be searching for that information. You would know it. Oh, yeah, and they had the props department had given me this blue Notepad with all the different steps written out but not in the same order not exactly so like actually if I looked at the notepad It would have messed me up, but I saved the notepad with all of Sprinkles' medications. And it's the one I hand Dwight in the scene.
所以你得抬起她的尾巴，把药膏抹在尾巴根部。我很高兴你把它背下来了，安吉拉，因为当我看到那个时，我在想。我以为答案是“是”，因为你的演绎就像你知道一样。如果你有一只生病的猫，你就会知道，对吧？是的，我不会去寻找那些信息的。你会知道的。哦，是的，道具部门给了我这个蓝色的记事本，上面写着所有的不同步骤，但顺序不对，不是完全一样，所以实际上如果我看着记事本，它会把我搞砸，但我保留了那个记事本，上面写着斯普林克尔斯所有的药物。这就是我在场景中递给德怀特的那个。
He's holding it. I saved it. I never tore off that first page and I still have it. And the whole notepad is unused. And that first page just has all of Sprinkles like medicines and how to care for her. Oh my gosh. Oh look, oh wait, oh I took a picture of it.
他拿着它。我留着它。我从来没有撕掉第一页，我到现在还留着它。整个记事本都是没用过的。第一页上写着斯普林克尔斯的所有药物以及如何照顾她。我的天啊。哦看，哦等等，哦我拍了一张照片。
Do you want to see? Yeah. Okay here. That is amazing, but that's not your handwriting. No, no, no, it's not my handwriting. Someone in the props department wrote that out. Wow. We have to post that on the pod.
你想看吗？好的，给你。太惊人了，但那不是你的字迹。不，不，不，那不是我的字迹。道具部门的某个人写出来的。哇。我们得把它发到播客上。
We'll post it on the pod. Okay. Sprinkle's medication going on the pod. Okay. Well we got a fan question from Tracy Prescott, who said this, I am a cat-focused veterinarian in Atlanta, and I was wondering if an actual doctor of veterinary medicine was consulted about Sprinkle's medical needs because Angela's list of medications and treatments she gave to Dwight were very realistic.
我们会把它发到播客上的。好的。斯普林克尔斯的药物要上播客了。好的。我们收到了来自特雷西·普雷斯科特的粉丝提问，她是这样说的：我是亚特兰大的一名专注猫科的兽医，我想知道在斯普林克尔斯的医疗需求方面是否咨询过真正的兽医学博士，因为安吉拉给德怀特的药物和治疗清单非常逼真。
Oh, that's fantastic! Well, Greg told me that he had the writer's assistance, Nate, Federman, and Jonathan Hughes do research into the accurate cat medicines, and that is why that list of medicines is so realistic. Well, good job, writer's assistance. of medicines is so realistic. Well, good job, writers' assistance. That's right. Well, listen, before we go on, maybe we should take a break because coming up, Michael is going to try to, I don't know, write this wrong.
哦，太棒了！格雷格告诉我，他让编剧助理内特、费德曼和乔纳森·休斯研究了准确的猫药，这就是为什么那份药物清单如此逼真。干得好，编剧助理们。药物清单如此逼真。干得好，编剧助理们。没错。好吧，听着，在我们继续之前，也许我们应该休息一下，因为接下来，迈克尔要试着，我不知道，纠正这个错误。
He's going to try. It's not going to go well. It never does. No. All right, we'll be back. All right. We are back. And Angela, Michael has gone into the break room in an attempt to rally everyone, to plant a tree in honor of Meredith. But do you know what I titled this scene?
他会去尝试的。过程不会顺利的。从来都没有。好吧，我们马上回来。好的。我们回来了。安吉拉，迈克尔已经走进了休息室，试图把大家召集起来，为了纪念梅丽塔而种一棵树。但你知道我给这个场景起名叫什么吗？
You are always titling scenes, and I have titled a scene. What? John eats popcorn. Oh my gosh. Did you notice he is eating popcorn through this whole scene, not carrots, not baby carrots, but popcorn, and the way he's eating it,
你总是给场景起名，我也给一个场景起了名。什么？约翰吃爆米花。哦天哪。你有没有注意到他在这整场戏里都在吃爆米花，不是胡萝卜，不是小胡萝卜，而是爆米花，他吃它的方式，
it's so, it's so delicate. Was he trying not to crunch too loudly? I think he was trying not to be a problem for sound, but he was clearly hungry because he eats it through the whole scene. Oh my God, was this the year we got that little popcorn maker by Craft Services? It must have been. This must have been the first week with the popcorn maker by craft services? It must have been. This must have been the first week with the popcorn maker.
太……太优雅了。他是在尽量不发出太大的嘎吱声吗？我想他是尽量不给收音造成麻烦，但他显然很饿，因为他整场戏都在吃。哦天哪，这就是后勤服务部门给我们那个小型爆米花机的年份吗？一定是的。这一定是在后勤服务部门有爆米花机的第一周。这一定是在有爆米花机的第一周。
We went a little crazy for popcorn and then the sound department, I think, said, okay, guys. I remember it went away. Yeah. But we were excited about it. Well, he's eating popcorn in this whole scene and it's also in the scene that Pam explains to Michael. You know, we're just going to go visit Meredith.
我们对爆米花有点疯狂，然后音响部门，我想，说，好吧，伙计们。我记得它不见了。是的。但我们对此感到兴奋。好吧，他整场戏都在吃爆米花，而且也是在这个场景里，帕姆向迈克尔解释。你知道，我们只要去看看梅丽塔就行了。
We're going to go and shift so we don't overwhelm her. But Michael is like, no, we're all going together. At the same time, I'll drive. So Jim and Pam are like, well, we can each take people in our separate cars and ask her's like separate cars. And Kevin's like, all right, I don't believe it. I know.
我们要分批去，这样就不会压垮她。但迈克尔却说，不，我们全去。同时，我开车。所以吉姆和帕姆就说，好吧，我们可以分别用各自的车带人去，安吉拉却说，分别开车。凯文就说，好吧，我不信。我知道。
Well then Michael has a talking head and he says, you know, I have flaws, you know, what, so sue me. And he's like, no, no, no, don't believe it. I know. Well, then Michael has a talking head and he says, you know, I have flaws, you know, what, so sue me. He's like, no, no, don't sue me. But Jenna, there was an alt to this talking head and it's in the deleted scenes. And it made me laugh so hard. And it's also in the bloopers. And Steve couldn't get through it.
好吧，然后迈克尔有一个访谈片段，他说，你知道，我有缺点，你知道，那又怎样，告我啊。他说，不，不，不，别告我。我知道。好吧，然后迈克尔有一个访谈片段，他说，你知道，我有缺点，你知道，那又怎样，告我啊。他说，不，不，不，别告我。但珍娜，这个访谈片段有一个替代版本，它在被删减片段里。这让我笑得太厉害了。而且它也在片场花絮里。史蒂夫根本演不下去。
He kept laughing. What is it? Okay. This is it. There's one take. Clearly he got through it because it kept laughing. What is it? Okay. This is this is it. There's one take. Clearly he got through it because it's in the deleted scenes. He says, I am not a bad guy. I am a good guy who runs over women with his car.
他一直在笑。那是什么？好的。就是这个。只有一个镜头。显然他演下去了，因为他一直在笑。那是什么？好的。这就是这个。只有一个镜头。显然他演下去了，因为这在被删减片段里。他说，我不是一个坏人。我是一个开车撞了女人的好人。
Why am I having such a hard time getting my message across? Oh my gosh, that is funny. And the way Steve does it is so good. That's good. I have to go watch that. Yeah, you have to. Well, we don't find out exactly how they get there, but the entire gang does arrive at the hospital.
为什么我这么难把我的意思传达清楚？哦天哪，太搞笑了。史蒂夫的演绎方式太棒了。太棒了。我得去看看那个。是的，你得去。好吧，我们不知道他们是怎么到那里的，但整帮人确实到达了医院。
Michael has a whole bunch of balloons. And the entire gang minus Dwight. That's right, because Dwight has gone to take care of sprinkles. Everyone gathers around Meredith's bed and we talked about this scene with Kate about how Steve improvised crawling on top of her in that one moment. He's like trying to give her a hug. It's pretty amazing. It's pretty great. There is a deleted scene from this moment. We're creed as they're exiting. Just grabs all her meds out of the little plastic cups. They're sitting on her tray. And creed just pockets all her meds. Of course he does. Well, I had a favorite moment from the scene
迈克尔拿了一大堆气球。整帮人除了德怀特。没错，因为德怀特去照顾斯普林克尔斯了。大家聚集在梅丽塔的床周围，我们和凯特讨论过这个场景，关于史蒂夫在那个时刻是如何即兴爬到她身上的。他正试图给她一个拥抱。这太神奇了。太棒了。这一刻有一个被删减的场景。克里德在他们离开时。直接把她小塑料杯里的所有药都拿走了。它们正放在她的托盘上。克里德把她的所有药都揣进口袋里。他当然会这么做。好吧，我有一个场景中最喜欢的时刻，
and I wanted to ask you about it because I think maybe you improvised it. When Michael is trying to get Meredith to forgive him, he says that she should think about the Bible because it says that forgiveness is next to godliness. And you mutter that's cleanliness. I did improvise that. Oh, I also wanted to mention in the scene the nurse who is an improv person from I.O. Her name is Sylvia McClure. Well I looked at her IMDB and I found this very interesting. In addition to playing a nurse on the office, she has also played a doctor on young and the restless Dexter and intelligence, a nurse in night of the dead, and a receptionist nurse on the unit. So she's played a lot of nurses and doctors, and incidentally she's also twice been cast as a nun.
我想问你关于它的事，因为我觉得也许那是你即兴发挥的。当迈克尔试图让梅丽塔原谅他时，他说她应该想想《圣经》，因为它上面说原谅仅次于神圣。你嘟囔了一句那是清洁。那确实是我即兴发挥的。哦，我还想提一下在那个场景里扮演护士的那位来自I.O.的即兴演员。她的名字叫西尔维亚·麦克卢尔。我看了她的IMDB，发现了一件非常有趣的事。除了在《办公室》里扮演护士，她还在《年轻和躁动不安的日子》、《嗜血法官》和《情报》中扮演过医生，在《死灵之夜》中扮演护士，在《急诊室的故事》中扮演接待护士。所以她扮演过很多护士和医生，顺便说一句，她还曾两次被选为修女。
That is very interesting, like sort of a, it's like a weird typecasting. Yeah, exactly. Well, I used to get a lot of auditions for school teachers and nurses. Have you ever played a nurse or doctor? Yes, actually, I played a pediatric nurse in this movie called The Promotion. I played a doctor on an episode of Monk. And I played a sexy nurse briefly in one of our Halloween
这非常有趣，就像某种……这就像是一个奇怪的特定形象定型。是的，exactly。好吧，我以前经常接到学校老师和护士的试镜。你演过护士或医生吗？是的，实际上，我在一部叫《促销》的电影里演过儿科护士。我在《神探阿蒙》的一集里演过医生。在我们在《办公室》的万圣节剧集之一里，我短暂地演过一个性感的护士。
episodes of the office. What were you most often typecast as for auditions? Before the office? Before the office. Quirky. Quirky gal. What's up? Like, quirky, quirky fun neighbor.
你在试镜中最常被定型为什么角色？在《办公室》之前？在《办公室》之前。古怪。古怪的女孩。怎么了？就像，古怪的、古怪有趣的邻居。
Quirky neighbor. Yeah. What's up? Like quirky quirky, quirky fun neighbor. Quirky neighbor. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I was, I got a lot of just the school teachers, waitresses and nurses. Well, I will tell you we talked about how hard we left in the scene, but 11 minutes, 22 seconds is when you can see us breaking. If you're looking for it, that's when Michael crawls on top of Meredith. Well, now we can go back to the office and we are going to find Dwight,
古怪的邻居。是的。怎么了？就像古怪的、古怪的、古怪有趣的邻居。古怪的邻居。是的。是的。是的。我接到了很多学校老师、女服务员和护士的角色。好吧，我得告诉你，我们谈过我们在那个场景里笑得有多厉害，但在11分22秒时，你可以看到我们笑场了。如果你在找的话，那就是迈克尔爬到梅丽塔身上的时候。好吧，现在我们可以回到办公室了，我们会找到德怀特，
telling Angela some bad news. And she's anxious to see him. She wants to know how it went. You can just tell. And then he's like, Hey, monkey. And she's like, any problems? Well, you left the TV on and your cat is dead. And my, my character's like, what?
告诉安吉拉一些坏消息。她急着想见他。她想知道进展如何。你一眼就能看出来。然后他说，嘿，猴子。她说，有什么问题吗？嗯，你把电视开着，你的猫死了。我的角色说，什么？
And he's like, sparkles, the white one is dead. Yeah, he gets the name wrong. It's bad. It is bad. This will not end well. Angela, you get so very immediately emotional and not in a funny way. Like this is one of the ways that our show
他说，斯普林克尔斯，白的那只死了。是的，他名字叫错了。这很糟。这真的很糟。这不会有好结果的。安吉拉，你立刻就变得非常情绪化，而且不是以一种搞笑的方式。就像这是我们的节目
allowed characters to be real people because Angela, the character really loved her cat and she is heartbroken. And you see that real pain here from your character. How did you gear up for this scene? Well Greg told me he said, you know, Angela Martin, hearing this news will be devastated. And I need you to play out the beats of hearing news
允许角色成为真实人物的方式之一，因为安吉拉这个角色真的很爱她的猫，她心碎了。你从你的角色身上看到了真正的痛苦。你是如何为这个场景做准备的？嗯，格雷格告诉我，他说，你知道，安吉拉·马丁听到这个消息会崩溃的。我需要你把听到消息的过程演绎出来
that kind of destroys you in the moment. You know, and I feel like we've all had moments in our lives where we've gotten that phone call with some bad news, unfortunately. And I just sort of thought about a few of those moments where at first you're just in total shock where you're not really sure what you heard. Yeah.
那一刻你真的会被击垮。你知道的，我觉得我们所有人的人生中，都不幸地经历过那种接到坏消息电话的时刻。我当时就在想其中几个瞬间，一开始你只会感到彻底的震惊，甚至不太确定自己到底听到了什么。是啊。
And then it's like someone slaps you in the face with the information. And then you're like someone slaps you in the face with the information. And then you're trying to make sense of it, but you can't make sense of it. It's unthinkable. And it doesn't make sense. And your body is doing all of that. You're in shock, you're sad, your mind is trying to make it right, but you can't make it right.
然后那种感觉就像有人拿着这些信息狠狠扇了你一巴掌。接着就像有人拿着这些信息狠狠扇了你一巴掌。然后你试图去理解它，但你根本无法理解。这简直不可思议。而且完全说不通。你的身体在承受着这一切。你处于震惊之中，你很难过，你的内心试图让这一切回到正轨，但你根本无法让它复原。
You can't figure it out. You don't understand why it happened. And I was just trying to process through all of that. And yeah, that's what I did. Did you have to do a lot of takes of that scene? Do you remember? No, I didn't. I was thankful for that.
你根本想不通。你不明白为什么会这样。我当时只是在努力消化这一切。是的，我就是这么做的。那场戏你拍了很多条吗？你还记得吗？没有，我没拍很多。我很庆幸这一点。
In the next scene, your character is still crying. She's standing at reception with Pam, and you look like you've been crying for a long time. What did you do to get there to start the scene in a place like that? You know, I'm chatty. So my instinct would be I'm standing by reception with you would be to be hanging out, you know, being part of the bullpen. So one of the things I did was I went around the corner by the elevators by myself in between takes and I did not hang out and I just tried to stay in sort of that sad space and and also the the makeup department they wanted my eyes to really look like I had
在下一场戏里，你的角色还在哭。她和帕姆一起站在前台附近，你看上去就像已经哭了很久。为了把这场戏开始时的状态演到位，你都做了些什么？你知道的，我很喜欢聊天。所以我的直觉是，我和你一起站在前台时，会去闲逛，你知道的，融入大家。所以我做的事情之一就是在转场间隙，一个人走到电梯旁的拐角处，我没有去闲逛，我只是努力让自己保持在那一种悲伤的氛围中，而且化妆部门他们希望我的眼睛看起来真的很像
bald my eyes out and they did so I had to get myself back in that emotional place and get sad again and also the makeup department, Kenneth Paul, who did my makeup, did like this type of eyeliner that really made the inside. It was like on the inside of your eye, reddish pink. So my eyes, my eyes looked the part and then emotionally I got there. Your eyes looked like you had three margaritas yesterday. Maybe that's what I, that should have been my prep instead of eyeliner and sad thoughts. No, what happened was Laverne just showed Kenneth Paul a picture of me from the previous day and was like, make her look like that. No, but in all seriousness, Angela, when I was watching these series of scenes where your character is really, really devastated over the death of sprinkles, I was just so beyond impressed with your performance and your range and your believability. It was just,
哭得稀里哗啦，他们确实做到了，所以我必须让自己重新进入那种情绪状态，再次变得悲伤，还有化妆部门，为我化妆的肯尼斯·保罗（Kenneth Paul），画了一种眼线，真的让内眼角看起来红红的。就像你眼睛内侧一样，呈红粉色。所以我的眼睛看起来很到位，然后情绪上也达到了那个状态。你的眼睛看起来就像昨天喝了三杯玛格丽塔。也许这就是我，那本该是我的准备工作，而不是眼线和悲伤的想法。不，实际情况是勒韦恩把前一天拍的一张我的照片给肯尼斯·保罗看了，然后说，让她看起来像这样。不，但说真的，安吉拉，当我看到这一系列戏时，你的角色真的、真的很为斯普林克尔（Sprinkles）的死感到崩溃，我对你的表演、你的戏路以及你的信念感真的印象深刻、惊叹不已。这简直是，
this is just great, great work. Oh, thanks. I appreciate that. I really appreciated Greg writing the storyline for me, and I got to do all these things, you know? And, you know, his take as a director was always to try to keep it as honest as possible. Yeah. Well, there's another really great moment in the scene, and we actually had a fan write-in.
这真的是非常、非常棒的表演。哦，谢谢。我很感激。我真的很感谢格雷格为我写了这条故事线，而且我有机会尝试了所有这些事情，你知道吗？而且，你知道的，他作为导演的理念一向是尽量保持真实。是啊。好吧，这场戏里还有另一个非常棒的时刻，实际上我们有一位粉丝写信来了。
Katie Harwick said, I think we need to give a shout-out to Michael when Angela's cat dies. Not only did he know her name, but he was overcome with grief. He cares so much for his employees, and it was just such a sweet moment to me. But I do have to ask, do you think he was truly sad or did he just see this as a distraction from hitting Meredith that everyone could talk about instead? I personally think he was very distraught about sprinkles. Well, I agree. This happens at 12 minutes, 41 seconds and it is one of my favorite endearing moments
凯蒂·哈威克（Katie Harwick）说，我觉得当安吉拉的猫死的时候，我们得对迈克尔表示赞赏。他不仅知道它的名字，还悲痛欲绝。他那么关心他的员工，对我和说这真是一个非常温馨的时刻。但我不得不问，你觉得他是真的难过，还是只是觉得这可以转移大家对撞倒梅雷迪思这件事的注意力，好让所有人都有个谈论的话题？我个人认为他为斯普林克尔感到非常心碎。嗯，我同意。这发生在12分41秒，这是我最喜欢的迈克尔的动人时刻之一
of Michael. Now, maybe because it's personal for me, because, you know, I played Angela Martin. I knew how much she loved her cats. But Michael, it's like that moment when the trick or treaters come to his house and you see his joy. It's like that moment when he shows up to Pam's art show. Yeah. Michael really saw these people as his family.
现在，也许是因为这对我来说很私人，因为，你知道的，我扮演过安吉拉·马丁。我知道她有多爱她的猫。但迈克尔，这就好比那些讨糖果的孩子来到他家时，你看到他脸上的喜悦。就像他出现在帕姆的艺术展时的那一刻。是啊。迈克尔真的把这些人当作他的家人。
So Michael knew Angela's love of sprinkles. Of course he did. And he was gutted to hear that sprinkles died. The way he puts his hand up to his face and he kind of collapses into the wall. And he's like, oh shoot. I'm sorry, Angela. I mean, could it get me worse?
所以迈克尔知道安吉拉对斯普林克尔的爱。他当然知道。听到斯普林克尔死了，他肝肠寸断。他把手抬到脸上的那个动作，然后他整个人瘫靠在墙上。他说，哦，糟糕。对不起，安吉拉。我的意思是，还能再糟吗？
He's feeling all of that. He really feels bad. And now he gets Sprinkle's name right the first time. And then he makes a big speech and calls her Prinkle. So, you know, he does. That's right. He says, so many bad things have happened today. The computer crashes from porn, Meredith is accident, and now Prinkels. We're cursed!
他感受到了这一切。他是真的觉得难过。现在他第一次就叫对了斯普林克尔的名字。然后他发表了一大通演讲，却叫她“普林克尔”（Prinkle）。所以，你知道的，他确实。没错。他说，今天发生了太多糟糕的事。电脑被色情内容搞瘫痪了，梅雷迪思出了事故，现在又是普林克尔。我们被诅咒了！
This seals the deal! To him, that's it. The office is cursed, and now he's got to figure out how to break this curse. Yes, but he does say, I'm not superstitious, but I am a little stitious. It's like he thinks they're two separate words. Well we had a fan question about that line from Jessica, Williard, and Lauren Corwin.
这算是板上钉钉了！对他来说，就是这样。办公室被诅咒了，现在他得想办法打破这个诅咒。是的，但他的确说过，我不迷信，但我有点迷信（stitious）。就好像他觉得这是两个独立的词。好吧，我们有一个关于那句台词的粉丝提问，来自杰西卡·威利德（Jessica Williard）和劳伦·科温（Lauren Corwin）。
They said that line makes me laugh every time who wrote this joke. I was curious too. Did you find out? I did. It was Jean Stupnitsky. Gene, hilarious. Yeah, I asked Greg and he said, I'm pretty sure it was Gene or Lee. I reached out to those guys. Gene said, yes, it was me. He remembers. They were in a group and this talking head leads to a commercial break and they needed a button.
他们说那句台词每次都把我逗笑，是谁写的这个笑话。我也很好奇。你查理吗？查了。是吉恩·斯图普尼斯基（Gene Stupnitsky）。吉恩，太搞笑了。是的，我问过格雷格，他说，我很确定是吉恩或李写的。我联系了他们。吉恩说，是的，是我。他还记得。他们当时在一群人中间，这个单人访谈引出了一个商业广告，他们需要一个包袱。
They needed a little button at the end of this talking head so that they could go to commercial. And he said they were just trying to come up with something and all of a sudden he said he shouted out, I've got it. This might be stupid, but how about this? And he pitched that line and it is so genius. It is such a good line. And I hear that line quoted all the time. It is a Michael Scott classic line. It is, it's true. Well, speaking of classic Michael Scott, we're now going to move into one of Michael's conference room meetings.
他们需要在这个单人访谈结束时有一个小包袱，这样他们就可以切入广告了。他说他们当时正试图想出点什么，突然他说他大喊了一声，我想到了。这可能很蠢，但这个怎么样？然后他抛出了那句台词，简直是天才之笔。这台词太棒了。我经常听到有人引用这句台词。这是迈克尔·斯科特的经典台词。确实，千真万确。好吧，说到经典的迈克尔·斯科特，我们现在要进入迈克尔的其中一个会议室会议了。
This is an epic conference room meeting. We were in this conference room all fricking day. We got loopy, we got punchy. I'm gonna tell you where we flat out lost it. It's so good. Yeah. I also remember that they very specifically did not seat Jim and Pam next to one another. This was part of Jim and Pam's supposed like way of deflecting that we're dating? Yeah. And I remember that you have to just be sad and kind of cry through this scene and that I didn't want to chat you up too much because I knew you had to stay in that space.
这是一场史诗级的会议室会议。我们在这个会议室里待了整整他妈的一天。我们都有点神智不清了，精疲力竭了。我要告诉你们我们在哪里彻底失控了。太棒了。是的。我还记得他们非常刻意地不让吉姆和帕姆坐在一起。这是吉姆和帕姆假装掩饰我们正在约会的方法的一部分？是啊。我还记得你必须在这场戏里保持悲伤并一路哭过来，而且我不想跟你多聊，因为我知道你必须保持那种状态。
And I did. I did. I really stayed sad until the end when Steve made me break into laughter. So Michael in the scene is questioning his employees. He feels like someone must have done something to get this curse, right? Like have they violated an ancient Indian burial ground? And then, you know, he wants to know what everyone's religious beliefs are, which Toby says Michael, we can't do that.
我确实保持了。我真的保持悲伤，直到最后史蒂夫逗得我笑出来。所以在这一场戏里，迈克尔在质问他的员工。他觉得一定有人做了什么事才招致了这个诅咒，对吧？比如他们是不是亵渎了古老的印第安墓地？然后，你知道的，他想知道每个人的宗教信仰是什么，托比就说，迈克尔，我们不能这么做。
You can't discuss that. Michael calls Toby Satan repeatedly in the scene, one because he won a week of free pizzas. So he's like, I don't think there's a curse. And Michael's like, okay, Satan. So he goes around the room. Pam and Darryl are both Presbyterians. They high five.
你不能讨论这个。迈克尔在这场戏里多次称托比为撒旦，首先是因为他赢了一周的免费比萨。所以他说，我不觉得有什么诅咒。然后迈克尔就说，好吧，撒旦。于是他在房间里转了一圈。帕姆和达里尔都是长老会教徒。他们击掌。
Phyllis has this great line where she says, I'm a Lutheran and Bob is a Unitarian, keeps things spicy. Creets said he's been a follower and a cult and a leader and a cult. The followers have more fun, but the leaders make more money. But Michael has decided he thinks,
菲利斯有一句很棒的台词，她说，我是路德会教徒，鲍勃是一神论者，这让生活充满情趣。克里德说他当过邪教信徒，也当过邪教头目。当信徒更有趣，但当头目赚的钱更多。但迈克尔已经下定决心，他觉得，
maybe we should do an animal sacrifice. Yes, you know, that's gonna do it. Maybe that would help. Yeah. And then he starts naming animals, but they don't exist. I wrote them down. He suggests that we sacrifice an animal
也许我们应该做一次动物献祭。是的，你知道的，这管用。也许那会有帮助。是啊。然后他开始说出一些动物的名字，但它们根本不存在。我都记下来了。他建议我们献祭一只动物，
that has the body of a walrus and the head of a sea lion or the body of an eagret with the head of a mere cat, or maybe one that has the head of a monkey with the antlers of a reindeer and the body of a porcupine. Okay, Jenna, when Steve started this runner, they just let him go. Do you remember this? Yes. He just started improvising different animal combinations. We didn't know what was going to come out of the guys mouth. We all started dropping like flies, cracking up, and the other thing is he would say it was such seriousness. And this was the comedy killer. And he said it was such seriousness. And this was the comedy killer, the long pauses.
它长着海象的身体和海狮的头部，或者长着白鹭的身体和猫鼬的头部，或者可能是一只长着猴子的头部、驯鹿的鹿角和豪猪身体的动物。好了，珍娜，当史蒂夫开始搞这个连珠炮似的发挥时，他们就由着他自由发挥了。你还记得这个吗？记得。他开始即兴发挥各种动物的组合。我们根本不知道这家伙嘴里会冒出什么来。我们所有人都开始像苍蝇一样倒下，笑到崩溃，而且另一件事是，他能一本正经地说出来。这就是喜剧杀手锏。而且他能一本正经地说出来。这就是喜剧杀手锏，那些长时间的停顿。
He takes such a long pause before he says, Body of a porcupine? Yes, we were on the floor. We were on the floor. I am not in any background shots while he's doing these animal combinations because I couldn't keep it together. And at 18 minutes, 11 seconds,
他在说出“豪猪的身体？”之前停顿了那么久？是的，我们当时都笑瘫在地上。我们都笑瘫了。他在组合这些动物时，我根本没出现在任何背景镜头里，因为我实在憋不住笑。在18分11秒的时候，
you can see Craig Robinson covering his face. I saw it. I remember that. We were losing it. It was so funny. And they let him go for a long time. I mean, you are not seeing all of it. He went for so long and I remember we were cracking up and we were just like get it like as a group we're like no get it together with you. So we're too good. We can't ruin these. Well while all this is happening at the office Dwight has gone to visit Meredith and he has this talking head where he's saying, as he's sitting next to her, that sometimes the best thing to do is to put an animal out of its misery. He's a farmer.
你可以看到克雷格·罗宾逊（Craig Robinson）捂住了脸。我看到了。我记得那个。我们当时都快笑疯了。太搞笑了。而且他们由着他说了好长时间。我是说，你们并没有看到全部。他说了好久，我记得我们当时笑得前仰后合，然后我们就像是一群人一样说，天哪，快进入状态吧。所以我们太优秀了。我们不能毁了这些镜头。好吧，当这一切在办公室发生时，德怀特去探望了梅雷迪思，他有一个单人访谈，坐在她旁边说，有时候最好的做法就是给动物一个痛快，结束它的痛苦。他是个农民。
Yeah, you could power a small fan for two days with the amount of electricity marathas hooked up to. I have to say, please, if you go back to rewatch this episode, during this speech by Dwight, next to Meredith's bedside, please look at the woman in the bed on the other side. Do you? Okay, over Dwight's shoulder. That's all I'm gonna say, just enjoy that performance
是啊，梅雷迪思身上插着的那些电线产生的电量，足够让一个小风扇转上两天了。我必须说，求求你们，如果你回去重看这一集，在德怀特在梅雷迪思床边发表这段演讲时，请看一看另一边病床上的那个女人。你看没看？好吧，在德怀特的肩膀后面。我只想说这些，下次你看这场戏时好好欣赏一下那个表演。
the next time you watch this scene. It's wonderful. Oh my God, Jenna, when we were all crammed around Kate's bed, that woman was there. I swear that woman, it was like she was a real patient. She let out some kind of noise and I thought we were all gonna shit our pants. She was a background actor, but it it was she was so real. She literally while we were standing there one time went like I think they told her to maybe make a moaning sound yeah and her interpretation of that we wouldn't
太精彩了。天哪，珍娜，当我们都挤在凯特（Kate）的床周围时，那个女人就在那儿。我发誓那个女人，就好像她真的是个病人一样。她发出了一种声音，我以为我们所有人都要吓得屁滚尿流了。她是个背景演员，但她真的是太逼真了。她有一次在我们站着的时候，字面意义上地发出了一声，我猜他们可能让她发出呻吟声吧，对，而她对这个要求的诠释简直让我们，
loopy. Well watch her in the background of the scene because she's excellent. So now the doctor comes in and Dwight has some questions for him. And you and I both know that this is our writer Justin Spitzer. Yes, creator of some of your favorite Dwitisms, Justin Spitzer. And the creator of the show, Superstore. Well, I reached out to Justin and he told me that he got this role after reading the part in the table read That he made Greg laugh which Paulie were seeing his shared that this would happen They wouldn't have some of the the roles cast and they would have writers read them and
神智不清了。好吧，在这场戏的背景里注意看她，因为她太棒了。现在医生进来了，德怀特有问题要问他。你和我都知道这是我们的编剧贾斯汀·斯皮策（Justin Spitzer）。没错，你最喜欢的许多“德怀特语录”的创作者，贾斯汀·斯皮策。也是剧集《超级超市》的创作者。好吧，我联系了贾斯汀，他告诉我说，他在围读剧本时读了这个角色后才得到了这个角色。他把格雷格逗笑了，正如保罗和我们之前分享过的那样，这种情况时有发生。有些角色他们不会选定演员，而是让编剧来读。
If a writer read a part get ready because Greg there was a good chance Greg was gonna put you in the show Well, he also told me that the look he gives to camera was actually him misunderstanding a piece of direction from Greg that Greg did not intend him to like perform that line to the camera as like a little joke like oh so that's where it went he's talking about Meredith Suteras. Yeah. But Greg left it in. I liked it. I liked it too, but he said that was not the intention. That was a mistake. Well, we learn in this scene that Meredith has been bitten by a bat, which we knew,
如果某个编剧读了一个角色，那就做好准备吧，因为格雷格很有可能会把你塞进剧里。好吧，他还告诉我，他给摄像机的那个眼神实际上是他误解了格雷格的一个导演指令，格雷格本来并没有打算让他把那句台词对着摄像机演得像个小笑话一样，比如“哦，原来它去那儿了”，他当时在谈论梅雷迪思的缝线。是啊。但格雷格保留了那个镜头。我挺喜欢的。我也很喜欢，但他说那不是本意。那是个失误。好吧，我们在这一场戏里得知梅雷迪思被蝙蝠咬了，我们早就知道了，
but not only by a bat, but recently by a raccoon and a rat. What the hell, Meredith? What is she doing? Honestly, a few of those animals could just live in her van. Meredith's van. Well, when Dwight comes back from the hospital, he fills Michael in. On all of this, he says, you know, it turns out Meredith had been exposed to rabies.
不仅是被蝙蝠咬，最近还被浣熊和大鼠咬过。搞什么鬼，梅雷迪思？她到底在干什么？说实话，其中有几只动物完全可以直接住在她的面包车里。梅雷迪思的面包车。好吧，当德怀特从医院回来时，他向迈克尔汇报了情况。关于这一切，他说，你知道的，原来梅雷迪思感染了狂犬病。
Michael's like, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding. And that going to the hospital might have saved her life. Because she got a rabies. Michael's like ding, ding, ding, ding, ding. And that going to the hospital might have saved her life because she got a rabies vaccine. That is all Michael needed to hear. He hit her with a car and saved her life. Yes, now he also says in the scene, Dwight says, the only way to treat rabies is to start treatment before the symptoms start.
迈克尔就像是，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮。去医院可能救了她的命。因为她打了狂犬病。迈克尔就像是，叮，叮，叮，叮，叮。去医院可能救了她的命，因为她打了狂犬病疫苗。这就是迈克尔需要听到的全部。他用汽车撞了她并救了她的命。是的，现在他在戏里还说，德怀特说，治疗狂犬病的唯一方法是在症状出现之前开始治疗。
Why looked it up? This is true. Did you know Angela that nearly 100% of people who develop symptoms die from rabies? Die. It cannot be cured once you get it. I did not know that. Yes, so this is why you have to seek treatment immediately if you are ever bitten by an animal. And a lot of animals can carry rabies. But since I looked it up, I'll let you know that in the United States, the most likely way
我查过了。这是真的。安吉拉，你知道吗，将近100%出现症状的人都会死于狂犬病？死亡。一旦染上是无法治愈的。我以前不知道。是的，这就是为什么如果你被动物咬了，必须立即寻求治疗。而且很多动物都会携带狂犬病。不过既然我查过了，我就告诉你们，在美国，传播狂犬病最可能的方式是，
to transmit rabies is through bats, coyotes, foxes, raccoons, and skunks. In Africa and Southeast Asia, it is stray dogs. I mean, what about monkeys? There's parts of like Indonesia, like if you go up to Ubud, like there's monkeys. Like all over the place. Any animal bite. If you get bitten by any animal, just go. Go get a rabies vaccine.
通过蝙蝠、郊狼、狐狸、浣熊和臭鼬。在非洲和东南亚，则是流浪狗。我是说，那猴子呢？有些地方比如印尼，如果你去乌布（Ubud），那里有猴子。到处都是。任何动物咬伤。如果你被任何动物咬了，直接去。去打一针狂犬病疫苗。
It also said, yes,ads? Yes! Any animal! If any animal bites you, I'm just telling you the animals that are most likely to carry rabies in these locations, but any animal can give it to you. Is a mongoose on the list? Is a mongoose any animal? I'm just messing with you when it's been really fun. Well, listen, here is the thing that I found most interesting. This is from the Mayo Clinic website.
上面还说，对，蟾蜍？对！任何动物！如果任何动物咬了你，我只是在告诉你这些地方最有可能携带狂犬病的动物，但任何动物都能把狂犬病传染给你。那猫鼬在名单上吗？猫鼬算任何动物吗？我跟你开玩笑呢，刚才真的很有趣。好吧，听着，我觉得最有趣的是这个。这是来自梅奥诊所（Mayo Clinic）网站的信息。
Here's what it says. Okay. If you wake up in the morning, Okay. And there's a bat in your room. Okay. You should assume you've been bitten because a bat can bite you without waking you up.
它是这么说的。好吧。如果你早上醒来，好吧。你的房间里有一只蝙蝠。好吧。你应该假设自己已经被咬了，因为蝙蝠咬你时可以不把你弄醒。
It also said, if you find a bat by a person who can't tell you that they've been bitten like a child or an impaired adult, assume they have also been bitten and go get a rabies vaccine. Because once you show symptoms, there is no cure. Well, I was watching an episode of Our Planet, and they were talking about these baby seals,
上面还说，如果你在无法告诉你是否被咬过的人（比如小孩或认知能力受损的成年人）身边发现一只蝙蝠，也要假设他们也被咬了，赶紧去打狂犬病疫苗。因为一旦你出现症状，就无药可救了。好吧，我当时在看一集《我们的星球》（Our Planet），里面讲到这些小海豹，
and they're vampire bats that go and try to just suck their blood. And they can hop. They hop around. The seals are the bats. The bats! They jump. I'm going to send you a video. They hop.
有些吸血蝙蝠会去试着吸它们的血。而且它们会跳。它们会蹦来蹦去。海豹是蝙蝠？是蝙蝠！它们会跳。我要发一段视频给你。它们会跳。
And they are blood suckers. They hop and bite. They hop and bite. Yeah. Well, well, there you go, guys. There you go. That's your rabies cheat sheet. That's everything you ever wanted to know about rabies.
而且它们是吸血鬼。它们又跳又咬。它们又跳又咬。好吧，好吧，就是这样，各位。就是这样。这就是你们的狂犬病小抄。这就是所有你想知道的关于狂犬病的知识。
Basically, if you get bit by an animal, that's what I learned. Get that rabie shot. Good. Oh, yes, that was the takeaway I was hoping for. There you go. Well, Michael is thrilled to find out that he has saved Meredith's life.
基本上，如果你被动物咬了，这就是我学到的。去打那针狂犬病疫苗。很好。哦，是的，这就是我希望你们领悟到的要点。就是这样。好吧，迈克尔得知自己救了梅雷迪思的命，兴奋极了。
Oh, yeah. He walks into the bullpen. He declares that the curse has been broken, turns out there is a God. Everything is great, but who is Jesus' dad? Yeah, he's not sure, I guess. And meanwhile, Kevin, you know, has been on the case this whole episode trying to figure out if Jim and Pam are dating.
哦，是的。他走进大办公室。他宣称诅咒已经被打破了，证明上帝确实存在。一切都很好，但耶稣的爸爸到底是谁？是的，他大概也不太确定。与此同时，你知道的，凯文整集都在调查吉姆和帕姆是否在约会。
He's positive that they are, but it's the end of the day and he's like, you know what? I guess they're not together. And now they probably never will be and it's too bad. Because they're like PB&J. Pam Beasley and Jim. Yeah. And that was an inside joke because at this point, fans of the show had started calling Jim and Pam Jam.
他坚信他们在一起了，但到了快下班的时候，他却说，你知道吗？我猜他们没在一起。而且他们现在可能永远也不会在一起了，真是太遗憾了。因为他们就像花生酱和果冻（PB&J）。帕姆·比斯利和吉姆。是的。这是一个内部笑话，因为当时节目的粉丝们已经开始把吉姆和帕姆叫作“果酱”（Jam）。
Yes. They had mashed our names as jam and so it was this funny thing that Kevin would call us PB&J and not jam. Well not to the fans. A little nod. Well you know what? We see Pam leave for the day. She gets in her car. She drives away, she's by herself. Clearly the documentary crew is as suspicious as Kevin because they follow her as she drives off. It made me wonder, my gosh, how long do they follow us after we leave work? Well, I don't think you should be that worried because Pam doesn't drive very far. I was like, Pam, do better. You drove like four car lengths and then you pulled over and then what? Are you going to just leave your car there?
是的。他们把我们的名字混搭成了“果酱”，所以凯文管我们叫“PB&J”而不是“果酱”，这就成了个搞笑的梗。不过粉丝们懂的。算是一个小小的致意。好吧，你知道吗？我们看到帕姆下班离开。她上了车。她开车走了，她孤身一人。显然纪录片摄制组和凯文一样满腹狐疑，因为他们跟着她开车驶离了。这让我不禁纳农，天哪，我们下班后他们到底会跟踪我们多久？好吧，我觉得你不用那么担心，因为帕姆没开多远。我当时想，帕姆，能不能行。你才开了大概四个车身的距离，然后你就把车停路边了，接着呢？你打算就把车留在那儿吗？
Your car is not that far from work and you're just going to leave it? No, I'm not going to leave it. I'm going to pick up Jim. I think they could have done better. Well, you know what? This is the street we could get a permit for, and we couldn't block off the whole street. This is as far as I was allowed to drive.
你的车离单位没多远，你就要把它扔在那儿吗？不，我才不扔呢。我去接吉姆。我觉得他们本可以拍得更好一点。好吧，你知道吗？这是我们能申请到拍摄许可的街道，我们没法封锁整条街。这就是我被允许开到的最远距离。
Well, but it's true, I pull over. And then Greg wanted to kind of further the misdirect, so he directed me to put my head down on the steering wheel. Like maybe Pam pulled off the side of the road because she was just having kind of an emotional moment and maybe you'd find out what that was or why that was, that she was sad or something like that. But of course what happens is Jim comes over,
好吧，但这确实是真的，我把车停下了。然后格雷格想进一步加强这种误导，所以他指挥我把头埋在方向盘上。就好像帕姆把车停在路边是因为她刚刚经历了一场情绪波动，也许你会发现那是怎么回事或者为什么会这样，比如她很难过什么的。但当然，接下来发生的是吉姆走了过来，
he gets in the car, they share a kiss, and then they drive away. Well, I loved this little moment that we got to see. I will say this. The way you slumped on this steering wheel, I did not think you were overcome with emotion. I thought you were awkwardly trying to hide. I'm gonna say when I watched that back,
他上了车，他们接吻了，然后他们开车离开。好吧，我很喜欢我们看到的这个温馨的小瞬间。我得说这个。你趴在方向盘上的那个样子，我一点都不觉得你是情绪崩溃。我以为你是在尴尬地躲藏。我得说当我回看那个画面时，
it's one of my worst acting moments on the show. I thought you were trying to hide. The idea was that I was sort of like, oh, what a day. I needed to pull over because, oh, what a day this has been. I need a moment to collect myself. I mean, it didn't work. I don't think it worked.
那是我在剧中最糟糕的表演时刻之一。我还以为你是在躲藏呢。当时的设定是，我有点像是，哦，这算什么日子啊。我需要把车停路边，因为，哦，今天过得真是一言难尽。我需要一点时间来平复一下心情。我是说，这没起作用。我觉得没起作用。
You thought I was trying to hide. I thought it, my thought. I thought it worked because I thought Pam was trying to possibly cover her face from anyone of her coworkers who might be leaving since she didn't pull very far away from the building Well, that's what I thought It was strange. It was strange But there you go and on the DVD guys, there is a very interesting extra feature. There is a rabies PSA. It is Steve looking like Steve.
你以为我是想躲藏。我觉得，我的想法是。我觉得起作用了，因为我以为帕姆是想尽可能地用脸挡住任何可能正在下班离开的同事，毕竟她把车停得离大楼并不远。好吧，我当时就是这么想的。这挺奇怪的。挺奇怪的。但就是这样，各位，在DVD上有一个非常有趣的幕后花絮。有一个狂犬病公益广告。那是史蒂夫，看起来就像史蒂夫本人。
Cute jeans button down. He has normal Steve hair. But he started delivering it more like Michael, but he's Steve. I don't know. It's like it was written for Michael, but it's delivered by Steve. It's a rabies PSA. Remember those things on NBC? Yeah, the more you know, Bing-bing-bing, or whatever.
可爱的牛仔衬衫纽扣敞开。他有着标志性的史蒂夫发型。但他开始演得更像是迈克尔，但他其实是史蒂夫。我不知道。就好像那是为迈克尔写的台词，但却是通过史蒂夫的口吻说出来的。这是一个狂犬病公益广告。还记得NBC电视台的那些广告吗？对，越多了解越受益（The more you know），叮-叮-叮，诸如此类的。
Yes. And he's giving a few like tips about rabies, and then he says rabies kills nearly 4,000 Americans every 1,000 years. Well, here's an interesting fact that I found Angela. What? Which is that? The day after this episode aired, this episode aired on September 27th, 2007. The next day was the first annual World Rhabies Day. It was a global health day to raise awareness of rabies. So do you think NBC had Steve do a PSA? I don't know.
是的。他给出了一些关于狂犬病的建议，然后他说，狂犬病每1000年杀死近4000名美国人。好吧，安吉拉，我发现了一个有趣的事实。什么？是什么？就在这一集播出后的第二天，这一集是2007年9月27日播出的。第二天就是第一届世界狂犬病日。这是一个旨在提高人们对狂犬病认识的全球健康日。所以你觉得是不是NBC让史蒂夫拍了个公益广告？我不知道。
I don't know. But what a weird crazy thing. Yes, and guys, if you get bit, get that rabies shut. I hope I made that clear in today's episode. I got it! I hope you also learned maybe don't drink three margaritas before you have a real early call time. Aspiring actors, maybe you can learn that from me today as well. Jenna, you're giving all kinds of gyms today. So many gyms.
我不知道。但这是一件多么离奇疯狂的事啊。是的，各位，如果你被咬了，去打那针狂犬病疫苗。我希望我在今天的节目里把这一点说清楚了。我记住了！我希望你们也学到了，也许在有非常早的通告时间之前，不要喝三杯玛格丽塔。有抱负的演员们，也许你们今天也能从我这里学到这一点。珍娜，你今天简直浑身都是干货（gyms）。全是干货。
Well, thank you. You're welcome. Here's the takeaway from me today. Save the boring emails and then no one will hack you. That's right. Oh, there we go. Guys, that was fun run. Part one. We'll be back next week with fun run. Part two, where we actually run. Oh, man, do we? Alright guys, have a great week! Bye! Bye! Are you still here?
好吧，谢谢。不客气。这是我今天给你们的收获。把无聊的电子邮件存好，这样就不会有人黑你了。没错。哦，就这样。各位，这就是《趣味长跑》第一部分。我们下周将带着《趣味长跑》第二部分回归，在那一集里我们真的要跑步了。哦，天哪，我们真的要跑吗？好吧，各位，祝大家过愉快的一周！再见！再见！你还在这儿吗？
Bye! Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Irvall, Jennifer Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Anzli Bubako. Our theme song is rubber tree by Creed Bratton. For at free versions of Office Ladies, go to stichoprenium.com. For a free one-month trial of stichoprenium, use code office. premium Use Code Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见！感谢收听《办公室女士》。《Office Ladies》由 Irvall、Jennifer Fisher 和 Angela Kinsey 制作。我们的制作人是 Cody Fisher。我们的音响工程师是 Sam Kiefer，助理制作人是 Anzli Bubako。我们的主题曲是 Creed Bratton 的《Rubber Tree》。想要收听无广告版本的《Office Ladies》，请访问 stichoprenium.com。要免费试用一个月的 stichoprenium，请使用优惠码 office。优质用户请使用优惠码 office。本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。